hey guys welcome back to another video
by simply learn this is a c plus plus
full course video and in this video
we're going to discuss all the important
topics and concepts that we need to
understand in order to learn the c plus
programming language
one by one we will go through each and
every topic of this course and learn
them along with some hands-on examples
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our channel and press the
bell icon to never miss an update we
will start by understanding the
introduction to c plus plus programming
then we will learn how to download and
install c plus plus in windows
after that we will learn how to write
the first program in c plus then types
and variables and if-else statements
we'll also look at the loops in c plus
plus and functions in c plus along with
call by value and call by reference
after that we will explore topics like
arrays strings pointers memory
management along with hands-on examples
then we will cover object-oriented
programming topics like classes in c
plus plus oops concept
and operator overloading and at last we
will cover some topics like vectors in c
plus stl and c plus plus enumerations
we'll also cover all these topics with
hands-on examples so that it will be
easy for you to understand so without
further ado let's get started so let's
start with the introduction to c plus
plus programming
c plus plus is a popular programming
language introduced by john strawstrom
in the year 1979. the aim was to make a
dynamic language that is efficient and
has some additional features to see
initially it was called c with glasses
as it was an extension to c language but
later renamed as c plus
it is general purpose case sensitive
language and it is called pre-compiled
language because it converts the source
code directly to the machine
understandable code
it is an intermediate level language
because it contains both features of
high level and low level language
c plus plus supports the features of
object oriented language like
encapsulation inheritance polymorphism
etc it also supports procedural
programming and functional programming
as well welcome to this video where
we'll be telling you how you can install
c plus plus on vs code and dev c plus
to download vs code let's go to google
and search for visual studio code
or vs code
we'll click on this first link
this is the official web page for
downloading the visual studio code
and we'll now click on this download for
windows blue button
and now we'll click on download now
here it is getting download and
as you can see
thanks for downloading visual studio
code for windows
once we are done with the download we
can click on this open folder
here it is
now we need to install this file so
we'll double click on this file
and this is the setup
wizard we'll click on this i accept the
agreement
and we'll click on next
as we have accepted the licensing
agreement now
we can select our destination folder or
we can leave it as it is but make sure
there must be 293.2 mb of free space on
that particular disk space
now
we'll click on next
here we can again click on next there is
no need to change over here
and now
you can click on this create a desktop
icon button or anyone else as per your
choice
now we'll click on next and now we'll
click finally on install
it is getting installed it will take
some time
now we can click on this finish button
launch visual studio we have marked it
it is already marked so when we click on
this finish button it will launch the
visual studio code
so as we can see this is the visual
studio code
so as we have installed vs code now we
have to configure it so that the c plus
programs can run in this code editor
so in order to do that we need to add
some extensions so we'll click on this
extensions button
now here we will write code runner
extension
right code runner
and this is extension
when click on this install
and it is getting installed
here are some instructions we can click
on control plus alt plus n
or press f1 and then select type run
code
but we'll deal with that later
now
[Music]
we'll add another extension that is
c
slash c plus plus
here it is
we'll click on this install
here you can see downloading visual
studio windows debugger
it is getting installed and i think it
is installed now
so as we have added both the extensions
so let's move on and do a program of cps
plus in this code editor
so the first program for beginners is
hello world program
in this program hello world is printed
it is very basic program and in the
first part of the program we are
including a header file hash include
iostream
header files are generally used to
import features into the program
functions like c in which is used to
take the input from the user and c out
which is used to display the output are
defined in this ip header file
here using namespace standard means
we are using all the things which are
within the standard library
the second part of the program is main
function this is a special function from
where the execution of program starts
inside the main function we are printing
hello world using the c out which is
used to print the output
return 0 on the next line will indicate
the program that nothing will return and
program executed successfully
so let's try this hello world program on
our code editor that is vs code
so let's first of all name the file
hello.cpp
so first of all we'll include the header
files
hash include iostream
and then namespace standard we'll write
using namespace
std
now we'll write the main function that
is int main
now inside this function
we will print using
c out
and we'll write
hello
world
after that we'll write return zero
all right now let's try to run this
as you can see hello world is getting
printed over here
so this is how it's done so now let's
move to our next topic
that is types and variables
coming to types and variables
in c plus there are different types of
data type that acts as a keyword which
is responsible to define a variable
first is boolean data type
this keyword is used when we have two
values either true or false and these
values are used when there are
conditions for example if the condition
is satisfied then it's true otherwise it
will return false
next is character data type
this character data type is used when we
are dealing with alphabets and symbols
and it is used to hold a single
character within the variable
integer data type
this data type is used for integer
values they can be both positive and
negative
next is flow data type
float is used when we want to store
values that are in decimal form
now variables
variables are used with these data types
it is generally used to store values
and this is the syntax to define a
variable
first we will mention the data type and
then the variable name of our choice
for example int is the data type and
data is the variable name our next topic
is strings
we can define strings as a collection or
group of characters
it is basically used to represent text
in the program
and we can perform many operations on
strings in order to manipulate it
the syntax of string contains a
collection of characters surrounded by
double quotes
for example here string is
the type
str is the name of the string and coffee
is the value that is assigned to the
string
in c plus there are two ways to create a
first is c style strings
in c style strings collection of
characters are stored in the form of
arrays they are basically areas of type
character
the second way is using string objects
we can create string object to hold a
string
they are implemented in the standard
library which we must include in the
program using hash include now let's
move on to the next example
so
let's make a new file
and name it as basic three dot cpv
so here we will do an example of string
and we'll do some push back and pop back
operation on it
so first of all we'll include the header
file
hash include iostream
then using namespace standard
namespace standard okay
now
we'll start with int main
all right first of all we'll write
string
data type
then the name of the string
s
here s is the name of the string
all right now
first of all we will display a message
to enter a string
so
okay enter a string
now
get line
this is the syntax when you want to take
the input
of a string
so
get line c in is used to take the input
and s is the name of the string
so this is how we take the input
and
now we will print another message saying
that
you have entered
now here we will print the string s
next line and then
okay
now
we'll do some operations like s dot
pushback
this will add an element at the end of
the string
so
let's say we want to add
y
so we'll write y inside the bracket
s dot pushback and inside the bracket
with single quotes we'll try it
y
now
we'll display a message saying
after
after using
pushback function
will print the string
that is after using the function push
back the string would look like this
and
now
we'll use another function as dot pop
back
it will delete the element from the end
so
we'll write c out
and we'll display the message
after using pop back function
let's write pop back only
and we'll print the
string
okay
now after that we'll write return 0
and i think it's done only the spelling
is wrong over here
okay
yeah now let's try to run this
as you can see the message enter a
string
so let's say i have entered
barcelona
so you have entered barcelona after
using pushback barcelona why
because we have used y
over here we want to add y at the end of
the string so after using pushback
barcelona y
and
pop back function after that we have
used and we know that it will delete the
element from the end so
here we can see there is no y pop back
function have deleted the element
so this is our output
next is if fell statements
if else are two conditional statements
that are generally used when we want to
run the code based on some conditions
we run a block of code which is inside
if statement only if the condition is
true for example if the number variable
here is equal to 10
then only the block of code will execute
and will print the message you got it
otherwise it will run the else block and
display the message written inside that
block which is not this one so first of
all we'll create a new file
we'll go to file and click on this new
file
now in order to save this one we can
click on control s or we can go over
here and click on this save as
now we can select the location
like
let's keep it over here only
let's name it as
visual dot cpp
dot cpp is extension which is used when
we want to do a program in c plus plus
now we'll click on this save button
now let's do a simple program to check
whether the program is running on this
code editor or not
so we'll include the header files
i should include iostream
now we'll write namespace standard
now we'll write int main
now inside intman will display a message
welcome to this video
okay now return zero
make sure to
save this after making changes or you
can click on control s
or you can go to file
and click on this save
so once you have saved the program now
you can run it
we can click on this play button
it will run the code
as we can see in the output welcome to
this video we can see
here it is
so
it means our program is working it is
running fine
now let's do another example in which we
will take the inputs from the user
so let's make a new file
we'll go to file and click on this new
file
now
we'll save as
and we'll write
visual 2 dot cpp
all right in this program we'll take the
input from the user
so start with
header files include iostream
our spelling is wrong
hash include iostream after that
using namespace standard
inside int main
will take the inputs from the user
will display the message
enter the
first
number
now using c in
we'll take the input
we forgot to mention this
declare this n1 variable so i'll write
into n1
and n2
and int
sum equals zero
all right here we have taken the input
of n1 the first number
now we'll take the input of another
number
by displaying the message
enter the second number
we'll write n2
now we'll
add both of these
and one plus
n2
and we'll display the result
we'll write end line
so that it looks good
all right now we need to save it
will go to file
and click on this save
now it is saved now we can run this
program
we will click on this run code
now in order to write the first number
over here that is in order to write in
the terminal we have to configure the
visual studio code
and to do that
we'll go to file
and we'll now go to preference
and in the settings we'll click on the
settings
and here we will type run in terminal
all right now we can scroll down
and here we can see code runner run in
terminal in my via studio it is already
marked but you have to mark this if you
want to
write in terminal or enter the inputs in
the terminal
all right once you have marked this you
can
close it and
then you can control s that is save
and then you can
close the vs studio and then open it
again
once you are done
now
let's try to run this
so now you will be able to write the
inputs
like let's say
the first number is 4
now the second number let's say
on addition it becomes 13 which is the
right answer
so these were some configurations that
you need to do if you want to run a
program of c plus in visual studio code
so as we have understood how to download
and configure visual studio code for c
plus plus programs
so let's move on to learn how we can
download dev c plus plus and run c plus
programs in that
so let's go to google
and type dev c plus
this is the first link
we'll click on that
now this is the green button
saying download will click on that to
download devc plus
as you can see it is getting downloaded
your download will start shortly
so now we'll click on download now
now it is getting downloaded
it will take a while the size of this
file is 48.1 mb
so as you can see the downloading is
almost done
so the downloading is complete now we'll
click on open folder
here it is dev c plus plus setup
now we'll click on this setup
we'll click on yes
the setup is loading
so now here we will select the preferred
language it is english we'll click on ok
now
we'll click on this is the license
agreement we'll click on i agree
now
we'll click on next
we don't need to change this i think the
space required is
346.8 mb
and we'll click on next
now if you want to change the
destination folder you can
but i don't want to change it so i'll
click on install
now it is getting installed
it will take a while
it's done and now we'll click on finish
and it is marked
so when we click on finish it will
launch the fc plus plus
so here we have to select the language
it is english so we'll click on next
here again we'll click on next and now
we'll click on ok
so this is our code editor that is dev c
plus plus
so let's write a code
first of all let's create a file
we'll go to file and go to new and click
on source file
all right now we need to save this one
and in order to save this we'll click on
file then we'll go to save as
and now we'll select the destination
and name it as
dev dot cpp
all right now let's start
with the header file
hash include iostream
we'll do a simple program over here
using namespace
std
because we want to check
that whether the program is running in
this editor or not
namespace std now we'll write int main
insident main will
display a message
welcome
to
dev
c plus
all right after that we'll write return
now let's try to run this
and in order to run this program we'll
go to execute
and now we'll click on compile and run
here this is the popup welcome to dev c
plus plus as we can see this is the
output
now press any key to continue it will
close this window
so our output is correct welcome to dev
c plus plus so this is how you can run a
program in dev c plus
and
our program was also working fine in the
visual studio code
moving on to while loops
in order to perform a particular task or
operation many number of times we need
loops
these are used when we want to execute a
block of statement repeatedly rather
than just writing those statements again
and again
for example imagine you want to display
your name on the screen 50 times
now to do that there are two methods
method one is writing your name 50 times
by doing the hard code
and method two is writing your name once
with the loop condition and your name
will be automatically displayed 50 times
now it is pretty obvious that you would
prefer the second approach
because you don't have to put effort in
writing your name 50 times plus it is
easy to write code in few lines
so method two is the functionality of
loop
it reduces time in writing the code plus
it increases the
simplicity now let's understand what is
a loop
loops in computer programming is a
series of tasks that are used to run
some particular code repeatedly until a
specific condition is met
loops tells the computer when to start
the condition and when to stop it
now this is a basic flow of a loop
after the initialization the condition
is checked if it's true then the block
of statement will get executed as long
as the condition is true
and if the condition is false the loop
will terminate
depending on the program different types
of loops are used in different times
so let's first see different types of
loops
first is for loop
then while loop then there is do while
loop
after that there is nested loop
these are four types of loops in c plus
plus so let's discuss these loops
first is for loop it is a repetition
control structure that is used to
iterate a piece of code based on the
condition is true or false if the
condition is true the statement inside
the low body is executed and once if it
returns false the execution of statement
will get terminated
and after every execution of for loop
the increment on decrement parts will
update the loop counter
now let's move on to the while loop
in this loop the condition is evaluated
first if it's true then the set of
instructions inside the loop body will
execute and this will happen repeatedly
until the condition becomes false
and when it becomes false the loop will
end
now the main difference is we use for
loops when we know the number of times
the body of the loop needs to run
whereas we use while loops when we don't
know the accurate number of times the
body of loop needs to run
now moving to the next loop that is do
while loop
this loop is quite similar to the while
loop in this the loop will execute the
set of instructions once before checking
if the condition is true
after that it will repeat the loop as
long as the condition is true
that means
in do while loop body will execute at
least once irrespective of the test
condition
now coming to the nested loop
when one loop is defined inside the body
of another loop then it is known as
nested loop
in c plus plus there are at least 256
levels of nesting
and the flow of execution for nested
loop is first it includes initialization
of variable followed by condition one if
it gets satisfied then it will search
for the second condition if that also
gets satisfied then it will get
increment and when the condition gets
satisfied it will search for the new set
of statements and follows the same flow
of execution
now coming to the control flow
statements
first is break statement it is basically
used to come out of the loop instantly
whenever a break statement is
encountered inside the loop the control
directly comes out from the loop by
terminating it
basically break statements are used when
we are not sure about the number of
iterations or we want the loop to end on
some condition
now we will discuss about continue
statement
continue is also a loop control
statement it is used to skip the current
iteration of the loop and control of
program goes to the next titration
in other words if continue is mentioned
inside the loop it skips the current
statement and transfer the control to
execute the next citation of the loop
now as we have discussed these topics
let's do some examples to understand
them better in our code editor that is
vs code
now we'll make a new file
and we'll name that file as
loops dot cpp
okay
oops one dot cpp
now here we will do a program in which
we have to print the digits from 0 to 10
using for loops
it will be a basic program just to
understand it
write the header file
hash include iostream
now i will write using namespace
standard
now here is the int name
now we will write the for loop with a
for keyword
inside the for loop
will initialize i with 0
now will put a condition i less than
equal to 10
which means
the loop will keep on executing
until i is less than 10.
now
we'll put increment
i plus plus
now inside the loop brackets all we have
to do is to print
i so that all the digits
get printed
so now let me tell you here what we are
doing is
we are just making the loop to run from
0 to 10 as we can see that i have made i
to i less than equal to 10 that means
loop will move from i 0 to 10.
now let's try to run it
here we can see
all the digits zero one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten
here is our answer and
let me tell you one thing more to put
return 0
after the loop it's a good practice
now i'll again run it
the output will be the same but it's a
good practice to write return zero in
the end
zero one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten
so instead of writing the hard code we
can just use the for loop in this case
it's a basic example of for loop but you
can try some more examples in order to
understand it better
now let's do one example of while loop
to understand it better
we'll be doing a basic example of while
loop in which all we have to do is to
print happy new year 11 times
let's start
first of all let's name this file
loops2.cpp
now let's start with the header file
that is hash include iostream
now we'll write using namespace standard
now here's the name
now first of all we'll declare n equals
zero we'll take a variable n and
initialize it with zero
now we'll put the while condition with
the while keyword writing while
n
not equal to 11.
here what it means is
the loop will keep on executing until n
becomes equal to 11
now here all we have to do is to print
happy new year so that it will get
printed along with the loop 11 times
and
now we'll write n
we have written n plus plus so that the
loop will keep on incrementing every
single time
after that now we'll write return 0
outside the loop
now we'll try to run this
so here's our output
happy new year 11 times so
this is how it's done
this is again a basic example of while
loop but to understand it better one
must practice some more examples on it
now let's do one example of do while
loop also
let's make a new file
first of all let's name that file
loops three dot cpp
i think the name is already taken
then we'll write loops four dot cpp
okay now so we'll write the header file
first of all
we'll write
hash include iostream
after that using namespace standard
now in this program all we have to do is
we have to print the sum of all the
digits from 0 to 9.
so let's start
we'll write into main
so now let's first of all declare a
counting variable sum and initialize it
with 0.
now we will initialize another variable
i
with zero
now the syntax of do while loop is
do keyword
and now we will add some code inside the
body
we'll write sum equals sum plus i
here what we are doing is we are simply
adding some variable and i variable and
storing it to some variable itself
we are doing this because we want to
find the sum
that is why we have to store it in a
single variable
now we will need to increment i or else
loop is going to run forever
now we will write file
i less than 10 we have written i less
than 10 because we want to find the sum
from 0 to 9
and make sure to put a semicolon in the
end in case of do while loop
now we will print
sum
in this while loop
will write sum is
sum variable
now this loop will keep on executing
till i is less than 10.
now in the do while loop sum is
calculated by repeated addition and
increment
in each repetition it is checked whether
the number i is smaller or equal to the
inputted number
if it is smaller then the loop continues
but exits the loop if it isn't
after the control exits from the loop
sum is printed
now let's try to run this code
here it is
sum is 45
which is the right answer this is our
output
so
this is how
it is done in two while loop
so now let's do one example of our last
loop that is nested loop
first of all we'll name the file
loops
pipe dot cpp
now we'll start with the header files
now using namespace standard
now in this program all we have to do is
to print a star pattern of half pyramid
form
using nested loop
so let's try
we'll write in
now let's initialize two variables that
is i
and j
now let's say we want to make a half
ramid of 10 rows
then it means we need to run a loop
which runs for 10 times
so let's write
or
initialize it to 0
i less than
i plus plus
now here we have written i less than 10
instead of this we'll write i less than
equal to 10 because we want the tenth
row to be printed also
now we will print slash n
in order to insert a new line
now we will write another for loop
which will decide
number of stars in a particular row
so we'll write j equal to 1
because
this for loop is for the column section
then j less than equal to i
which is a row
then g plus plus
now we'll print
star
now one more thing instead of 0 we'll
write i equals to 1
because we want to print stars from 1 to
so now let's discuss it's working
initially we have i equals to 1 that is
the outer loop value
now for this value a complete run of jth
loop is happening
that is j equal to 1 validated by j less
than equal to i
now this condition is used because the
pattern which we are going to build is
having increment of star as the number
of rows increments
so for i equals to 1
j equals to 1 is executed
then j plus plus is done
which increments the value of j to 2.
now
j equals to 2 failed to execute as 2 is
less than equal to 1 is false
therefore only 1 star is printed
[Music]
again we go to ith loop
now for i equal to 2 we will check every
value of j which can be executed that is
1 and 2.
since only 2 values can be true
therefore 2 star are printed
similarly we check for i equal to 3 4 5
and so on till 9 as we have the
condition i is less than 10
so now we'll try to run this
and check
whether the pattern is printing or not
here it is
half pyramid form using stars
with the help of nested loops
so this is our star pattern
we can make some more different types of
patterns using nested loops
but we have done only one example in
order to understand the concept
so now let's move to our control flow
statements
and let's do some examples of them
okay now
make a new file
and let's name this file as
control 1
dot cpp
now we'll write the header file and the
name space standard as we have done
previously so let's do it
dash include
live stream
using namespace std
now here
we will write a program in which we have
to print the numbers from 100 to 200
like 110 120 130 with the gap of 10
but after 150 we will terminate the
ongoing loop
now how can it be done with the help of
break statement
so let's start
first of all we'll write intermittent
now we'll take a variable num
and initialize it with 100.
now we'll write a while condition
and we'll write num is less than equal
to 200 because we want the loop to run
from 100 to 200.
num less than equal to 200
now we'll simply display those numbers
now we'll write an if condition
that if num equals 150
then we'll terminate the loop and for
that we have to write the break
statement inside the if statement
so let's write
if num equals equals 150
then we have to break
the loop
write the break statement
now after that we'll increment this
by 10.
we're incrementing this by 10 because we
want
the numbers to be printed like 100 110
120 like this
that is why we are incrementing it with
10 and not with one
now we'll write out of the loop
just to be informed that we are finally
out of the loop
return 0
now we'll try to run this
here we can see yeah here we can see
hundred hundred and ten hundred and
twenty
up to hundred and fifty after that
we are out of the loop
this means
the code works fine
so this is the example of a break
statement
now after this we'll do another example
of
continue
so let's start
let's make a new file
and name it
control 2 dot cpv
now we'll write the header files
[Music]
using namespace standard
now in this program all we have to do is
to print the numbers from 100 to 90
only excluding 96 from them
now how do we do it with the help of
continue statement
so let's start
first of all we'll write into main
now we'll declare a variable
num and initialize it with hundred
now we'll write a while condition
while loop in which we write the
condition
num greater than equal to
90 because we want the loop to run till
it is equal to 90
that is why we have wrote greater than
equal to 90 basically we want the loop
to run from 100 till it
becomes equal to 90.
now inside the loop we'll write the if
condition
in order to skip 96. so we'll write
if
num equals 96 num
quilts equals 96.
now we'll use a decrement operator
because our starting point is 100 our
ending point is 90 that is why we have
to use the decrement operator
now continue statement
after that
write
value is
and we'll write the variable number
now we'll write num minus minus
here we are writing minus minus because
we want it to get decrement after
printing also that is why we have
written num minus minus after printing
num
now let's try to run this also hope it
works
okay i think there are some errors
so
[Music]
some brackets were missing
and we'll write return 0
now we'll try to run it
here it is
as you can see
199.98 97
but 96 is missing
so this is all we have to do in this
program
and this is the basic example of
continue statement
in order to understand these examples
better you must try more examples on
each of these loops and control flow
statements so that it will be easier for
you all
moving on to what is a function
functions are blocks of code that are
designed to perform a specific task
it basically divides the complex problem
into smaller portions and make the
program easy to understand and reusable
and by reusable it means we can define
the code once and we can use it many
times
we can also pass data into the functions
in the form of parameters
and this is the syntax
first is return type of the function
then we will write function name
then inside the bracket these are the
parameters
now let's discuss why we use functions
functions make the program less
complicated because once function is
defined in the program then it can be
used over and over again
which reduces the complexity of code
and it helps in avoiding the duplicity
of code and it reduces the amount of
code
due to this we can easily debug and
maintain the code
now coming to the types of functions
there are two types of functions in c
plus
that is built in functions and user
defined function
now let's discuss these functions
first is built-in function
these are also known as predefined
functions or library functions
we don't need to define these functions
because these are already present in c
plus plus libraries and the
implementation of these functions are
also available in library file
and to use these functions we don't have
to write them separately we simply call
them
now coming to the user defined functions
c plus plus allows us to define our own
functions
these functions are created by
programmers according to their
requirement
this allows a way to wrap a set of
statements to perform a specific task
and that group of statement is given a
name so that it can be invoked later
from any part of the program
following is the example of user defined
function
here club is a user defined function
with the return type wired and it is
being called from the main function
now
let's learn about function declaration
function declaration basically acts as
an identification for the function
it informs the compiler about the
existence of function
function's name
the number of parameters in the function
and its return type
these things acts as an identifier for a
function
and this is the syntax for a function
declaration
first we will write the return type then
we will write the name of the function
after that inside the bracket we will
write the number of parameters
for example in this chess function
int is the return type
chess is the name of the function
and inside the brackets these are the
number of parameters
although we can write the names of
parameters but names of parameters are
not important in the function
declaration only their type is required
now let's learn about function calling
in order to use a function we'll have to
invoke or call a function
when a program calls a function the
control of the program is transferred to
the called function and when the code
function completes its task then the
control is returned back to the main
program
so the functions are called by writing
the name of function and after that
writing the required parameters inside
the brackets
and this is the syntax
first we will write the function name
and after that we will write the
arguments which you want to pass
for example sum is the function name and
a and b are the arguments
moving on to another video on call by
value and call by reference in c plus
call by value is a method in which
copies of variables are passed to the
functions and as the copies of variables
or arguments are being passed so that is
why the changes that are done inside the
function does not affect the arguments
and this is the syntax inside int main
we can see that we are calling a
function and passing the values
here val1 and val2 are the actual
parameters
these are those which are passed to the
functions
and inside the brackets of call function
we can see
n1 and n2
these are formal parameters
foreign parameters are those which are
received by the function
so here we can say values of actual
parameters that is val 1 and val2 will
be copied to the formal parameters that
is n1 and n2
now let's have a look at an example
in which we are swapping two numbers
as we can see inside int main we have
assigned 120 to x and 152i
after that we have called a function
named swap it
and inside the brackets we are passing
the values of x and y
and these values are getting received by
called function
and inside that function there is a
logic to swap the code with the help of
temporary variable temp
and these values of x and y
are then displayed inside int main
but its output is same
x is still 120 and y is still 150 there
is no change after swapping it also
so this shows that actual value of the
variable is not getting modified
this shows that changes done to the
parameters inside the function
does not affect the arguments
now let's learn about call by reference
in this method instead of passing the
arguments the address of the argument is
passed to the formal arguments of the
function
and the address is used to access the
actual argument referring to the same
location so any changes that are made
gets reflected to the actual parameter
this is the syntax of call by reference
in which we have assigned 200 to the
variable num and then the address of
this variable is passed to the function
and 20 is assigned to it
now on displaying the output the value
would be 20 and not 200 because the
value is assigned to the memory location
that is why change is getting reflected
now let's have a look at an example of
swap
this is the same example as that of the
call by value but instead of passing the
copies of variable we are passing the
address of the variable
and inside the function values are
getting swapped
with the help of temp variable
and then it is getting displayed in the
main function
in this case we can see in the output
the values of variables are actually
swapped
m is now 300 and n is now 250.
now let's do some examples of call by
value and call by reference in our code
editor that is vs code
now we will do an example of call by
value
in which we will try to change the
salary with the help of a function
so let's start
first of all let's make a new file
and name it
call one dot cpp
now we will include the header files
hash include
iostream
now we will add namespace standard
now first of all we'll write intmin
and we will declare a variable cell
and assign a value 27 000 let's say
salary
to this cell variable
now we will call a function
let's name that function as
salary
underscore change
and now
inside the brackets will write
cell
as we know that in call by value
we pass the copies of the variable
so
now we'll display
that variable
we'll write
value
inside main
and now we will write the variable name
cell
and
handle
now
return 0
now let's make
the function salary change
we'll write
void
salary underscore
change
it's void
now here we will write
hint the data type
and the variable
s that is the formal parameter
sal here is the actual parameter and s
is the formal parameter
now
we will assign as a new value
let's say thirty thousand
here we have assigned as thirty thousand
earlier the value of cell was twenty
seven thousand and then we passed the
copy of the variable cell
to the function shall we change and
there we assigned 30 000 to it
so let's print over here
value
inside
function
[Music]
cell
and l
here we have to write s
because the variable name is s
okay now let's try to run this
here we can see
value inside function is 30 000
and value inside main is 27 000
here we can see the value of the
variable that is passed gets changed but
the original value inside the main
function doesn't changes
so we can say changes are not reflected
to the original value which happens in
call by value method
so now let's do one example of call by
reference
let's make a new file
call to
dot cpp
let's include the header files
hash include
iostream
now we'll write using namespace standard
now we'll start with int main
here we will declare a variable cell
and assign 27000 to it
as we have done previously
now we will call a function named
increment
and inside the bracket we will pass
the address of cell
as we know that in case of call by
reference we pass the address
so after that we'll just
write the
message saying
salary
[Music]
inside
main
and
we'll write
the variable cell
then end l
after that we'll write return 0
now our job is to write the
function
we'll write void
increment
and here
we write ampersand sign
s
because here we are passing the address
not any copy of the value or the
variable here we are passing
the address of the variable
so that is why we have used ampersand
sign
now
we will simply write the logic to
increment
so we'll write s equals s plus
5000 let's say we want the sally to
increment by 5000
then
we will display
the variable s
so first of all we'll write the message
salary
inside
function
the name of the variable after that and
l
now let's try to end this
here we can see that the salary inside
the function is 32 000 and salary
outside
the function that is inside the main
function is 32 000 as well
here we can see that the changes are
reflected to the original values as well
in the main function and we know that in
case of call by reference any change
inside the function is reflected outside
the function because we are passing the
address of the variable
so this is our output 32 000 and 32 000
so these were some basic examples of
call by value and call by reference now
here we will do a program in which we
have to do the sum of two integers with
the help of function
so let's first of all
make a new file
function dot cpp
okay so let's start first of all we'll
declare the header files
that is hash included stream
now the name space standard
now we will write int main
now inside end main we will declare a
variable named s
here we have declared this variable
because we want to store the sum of
those two integers in this variable
so
we'll call the function let's say let's
name the function as sum
and let's
assume the variables to be 5 and
5.
here sum is the name of the function and
5 comma 5 are the arguments
now we'll make the function sum
here end
is the return type
sum is the name
and
paint a
component b
are the parameters
so in this function we'll write the code
to do the sum of these two integers and
for that we have to store the sum in a
variable
for that we will now declare a variable
c
now we will write
c equals
a plus b
here we are storing the sum of a plus b
into the variable c
now as we know that the return type
isn't so we have to return the variable
instead of printing it
will write
return
c
now in the main function
we'll print that variable
we will print the variable s
because after the function completes its
task of addition the output will come
back to the calling function which is
getting stored in the variable s
so
we'll write
the result
is now we will write the variable s
let's see
hope it runs
the result is 10
5 plus 5 on addition will get 10
let's write 3
and again
try to run this
the result is 8
5 plus 3 equals to 8 so this is the
right answer
now we will do another example
of c plus function
in which we have to find the larger
number operator number among two
elements
so let's do that
let's create a new file
function1.cpp
now we will include the header files
hash include iostream
now using name space standard
now first of all we'll write the intent
now the variable n1
now we will declare another variable n2
these are the two variables among which
we have to find the greater number
so
we'll display a message saying that
enter
the first number
now we will take the input
and one
now we'll do the same for the other one
we'll write
enter the second number
we'll input the second number
now
we have to make a call to the function
named let's say
maxi
and we will pass these arguments
n1 comma n2
now let's make this function maxi
the return type is void
maxi
is the name
we'll write the variables n1
and 2.
now we'll write the if condition because
we have to find the greater number among
both these elements so we'll write the
if condition
if
n1 is greater than n2
then it must print the n1
will also display a message saying that
the larger number is
n1
if n1 is greater than n2 then we'll
display the n1
and
if n2 is greater
then we'll display the n2
we'll write the variable n2
so let's see if that runs or not
i think we have to write the first
number here we can see enter the first
number
enter the first number
so
we'll write let's say
and the second number would be
78.
the larger number is 78
so
among both the numbers as we know that
70s is greater than 56 so this is how we
can show it with the help of functions
so these were some basic examples of c
plus first functions in this video we
will be discussing what is recursion
recursion can be defined as a process in
which a function calls itself again and
again until a certain condition is met
recursion basically brings about several
number of iterative calls to the same
function
however it is important to have a base
case 2 and the recursion for example
imagine you are calling your friend
again and again for an urgent piece of
work until he picks up the call
now here calling your friend again and
again or one after the other is a
recursive function and when he picks up
a call is the termination condition and
this is the basic syntax where the
function name is recursion and it is
being called from the main function and
inside the recursion function it is
calling itself now
let's understand it's working
in a recursive function there are two
parts that is the recursive case and the
base case
in the recursive case the function is
being called by itself again and again
and the base case is when the function
finally stop calling itself
so when the recursive function is called
from the main function then the call
function will execute and it keeps on
repeating as it is being called by
itself from within the function again
and again until it meets the base case
that will terminate its calling
for example factorial of 5
in this problem we can see a pattern
n into factorial of n minus 1
to be clear n is 5
so n minus 1 is 4
and it is going on till n becomes 0
here factorial is the recursive function
and n minus 1 is the argument that is
getting passed for every n into the
recursive function
in this case if n becomes 0 or 1
it is the base case and n
into factorial n minus 1 is the
recursive condition
now
let's understand the types of recursion
first is direct recursion as the name
suggests in this type of recursion
function calls itself directly for
example void recursion here recursion is
the name of the function and is being
called by itself from within the
function directly
although there is no base case in this
example but it shows the idea of direct
recursion
now coming to indirect recursion
when a function calls itself indirectly
that is if a function calls some other
function to make a recursive call then
it is known as indirect function
for example here recursion function is
calling some other function sub
and sub function is calling the
recursion function here both the
functions are calling other functions to
make a recursive call this is called
indirect recursion
now coming to advantages and
disadvantages of recursion
the advantages are in recursion we only
need to define the base case in the
recursive case
so therefore it provides a simple and
clean way to write a code
second is recursion is more preferred in
problems like tree traversals tower of
noise graphs because these are
inherently recursive problems
now
disadvantages
disadvantages are the recursive program
generally acquires more space than the
iterative program
this is because after every call to the
function each function call will keep on
adding to the stack until the base case
is reached
second is it requires more amount of
time because of function calls
now let's do some examples of recursion
on our code editor that is vs code
now here we will do a program in which
we will find the sum of natural number
up to a number which we will enter and
we will do this example using recursion
so let's start
first of all we name this
recursion
dot cpp
okay now we will start with writing
header file
that is hash include
iostream
now
we'll add namespace standard
using namespace
std
now first of all we'll write entman
now we will declare a variable
let's say num
so basically we want to enter a number
so for that first of all we'll display a
message saying that enter a number
now we'll take the input
input as num
so now here we will make a call to the
function and in that function we will
pass the variable num which we have
taken the input of and we will print
this with a message
so let's say
we'll print it like c out
and the message would be
sum is
and this is the function name sum
and this is the variable which we are
passing
after that let's write return 0
now let's make this function sum
we'll write
int
the return type
sum the name of the function
and
the variable num
now first of all we have to make a base
case
so we will write the base case as will
make if
num
is not equal to 0
then
here we will write the recursive case
return
num
plus
sum
num minus 1.
so here we are adding the numbers with
its previous number and because of
recursive condition it will keep on
calling the same function sum function
again and again till the base case that
is num becomes equal to 0 is achieved
and once it is achieved the calling
would be stopped
num not equal to 0 here means that if
num is not equal to 0 then only this
statement num plus sum num minus 1
will execute
okay so
now
after this
we'll
try to run this
enter the number let's say
sum is 15 here we can see
sum is 15
okay let's recheck
5 plus 4 equals to 9 9 plus 3 equals to
12 12 plus 2 equals 2 14 14 plus 1
equals to 15 so our answer is correct
so this is how we can find the sum up to
any numbers
which you want to find the sum of
and
now let's do another example
so let's name this as
recursion
2 dot cbp
now here we will do a program of
factorial we will enter a number and we
have to find the factorial of that
number
so let's start
first of all we'll write hash include
iostream
that is the header file
now
using namespace standard
now we'll write int main
okay now we will declare a variable
number
and we want to take the input from the
user so we'll
display a message saying
enter the number
now we will take the input
will write number
now we will call a function
and we will send the pass the argument
number as we have done in the previous
question
so let's do it
first of all we will display that saying
the factorial
of the number
you have entered
is
now we will make a call to the function
let's say the name of the function is
fact
and
we'll pass the argument number
as we have done previously
now we'll write
return
now let's make this function
we will write the return type
int
now
fact
after that now we will write the
argument
and number
now we will write if condition
and will write
number
less than
and we will return
so here we have wrote this condition
because
as we know that the factorial of 0 is 1
and
if a number is less than 1 that it means
it is 0
and if it is 0
then our program should return 1
and
we will write now else condition
else
if it is not 0 that means
we will write the recursive
condition
that is
number
into
fact
number
-1
now this is the condition that is
responsible for finding the factorial of
a number
for example if we input 5 then here we
can see the condition would become 5
into fact 5 minus 1
that is 4
and this 4 will be passed as argument to
this fact function
and then the condition would become 4
into fact 4 minus 1 that is 3 and it is
also passed to the function
and similarly it will go on until it
becomes less than 1.
now let's try to run this
enter the number
let's say six
the factorial of number you have entered
is 720 and we know that the factorial of
6 is 720 so this is the right answer
and let me tell you this is this is the
base case and this is the recursive case
in this program
now after that let's do one
last example of recursion
okay so now let's make a new file
and name this file
now first of all we'll add the header
files
iostream
now namespace standard
using name
space
standard
so here we will do the program of
fibonacci series and we know that
fibonacci series is basically each num
in fibonacci series each number is
basically the sum of its two previous
numbers
so let's start
so first of all we'll
make int main
now
we'll declare a variable num
now we want to take the input from the
user so
first of all will display a message
saying that
enter the number
now we will take the input
will write
num
now
we will make a for loop and i trade that
loop from i0 to num
so we'll write for keyword
int i equal to 0
i
less than
num
i plus plus
now inside the loop we will write c out
to display and we will call fibo
function
and we will pass i as an argument
because we want to print the series
so we will write
c out
fibo
and we'll pass i
as an argument and
just for the space
now i will write return
zero
in fibo function we have passed i as an
argument because we want to print the
series
so first 0 will be passed then 1 will be
passed after then 2 will be passed and
so on
so now we will make the function fibo
int is the return type fibo is the name
now the argument number
now in this fibo function we will put if
condition for checking if the num is
equal to 0 or 1
if yes we will return the value of num
else we will recursively call fibo using
n minus 1 and n minus 2 because
fibonacci series is basically the sum of
previous two numbers
so first of all we'll write
if
num
is less than equal to 1
then
return
num
else
return
fibo
num
minus 1
plus
fibo
brackets num minus 2
because we know
fibonacci series is basically the sum of
previous two numbers
now if the
num is 0 or 1
then it will go to the if statement and
if it is greater than 0 and 1 then it
will go to this recursive statement
so for example if n equals to 2 then we
will call recursively 2 minus 1 and 2
minus 2 that is 1 and 0 respectively
since 2 minus 1 will give 1 and 2 minus
2 will give 0 these will be evaluated in
if statement as they are less than equal
to 1 so it will give 0 plus 1 that is
equal to 1.
now let's try to run this code
enter the number
let's say 6
zero one one two three five which is the
right answer
the fibonacci sequence for six is zero
one one two three five
so this is how we can do fibonacci
series or fibonacci sequence with the
help of recursion
and i suggest you to do some more
examples on recursion to understand it
better
moving on why we need header files
header files allows us to assemble all
the predefined functions in one place
and it is helpful because it is easier
to gather the declarations in one place
and then use them whenever we need them
and as all the declarations are gathered
in one place so it automatically reduces
the complexity and it also decreases the
number of lines of code
there are many functionalities of header
files one of them is it helps in taking
the input from the user and also helps
in displaying the output in a program
now let's learn what actually a c plus
header file is
header files are the set of libraries
that contains predefined functions at a
common place so it basically stores the
declarations at one common place and
they are being used while writing a
program
these header files usually have a dot h
extension and we use hash include before
writing the header file to inform the
preprocessor that we are including this
header file now let's discuss types of
header files
there are two types of files in c plus
plus first is predefined header file
these files are already present in c
plus plus compiler we simply need to
import these header files using hash
include which will inform the compiler
about the header file and then we can
write the name of the header file
between the angle brackets
next is user defined header file
these header files are defined or
created by users in c
user can create their own header file
and include it in the c plus library and
it can be used whenever it is required
now let's learn how to create this
header file
in order to create your own header file
first of all we will write the c plus
code which we want to use whenever we
want
after that we will save the file with
dot h extension
as we can see in step 1 we have written
the code of two integers that are
getting multiplied
and now we will include this in the
program
to include this in the program we will
use hash include and after that we will
write the name of the header file inside
the angle brackets with the dot
extension
here hash include will inform the
compiler that a header file is added
and now as we can see in step 2
after the declaration of two integers we
are calling the function product and
passing the arguments x and y
after running this program we will get
the output as 45
because 9 into 5 equals 45 and we don't
need to worry about writing the logic of
it because we have already included this
header file
now let's have a look at some examples
of header files
hash include iostream iostream is the
header file that is used to read and
write the standard input output streams
because of this header file we can take
the input and display the output and in
case of iostream dot h is not used
because after standardization of c plus
plus io stream became standard header
whose function is now in std namespace
unlike earlier when functions were
defined in iostream before
standardization
next is f stream
f stream are associated with files it is
basically used to read the information
from files and write the information in
it
and next is io manip
io manip is a library that is used in
the manipulation of input and output
statements
so these were some examples of header
files in this video we'll be discussing
about c plus plus array so first is need
of arrays
we use arrays because it allows us to
store similar type of data within
contagious block of memory
and it allows us to iterate through
those variables conveniently using
indexing
usually an array is used to store
similar kind of data like marks scored
by all the students of a class and
record of attendance of all the
employees in an organization
now moving to what is an array
an array can be defined as a collection
of similar kind of elements these are
always stored in contiguous memory
locations that is one after the other
the total number of elements in an array
is called the length of the array
now this is the way you can visualize
the n array
here each block is capable of storing
data values of some type in sequential
manner and each element can uniquely
identify by its index in the array
and this is the syntax of array
int is the data type
array is the array name and 5 is the
size of array
now there are few types of array nc plus
plus
those are one dimensional array two
dimensional array and multi-dimensional
array
so let's first of all discuss 1d array
this is the simplest form of an array in
this array data items are arranged
linearly in one dimension having single
index value to represent data elements
now this is the syntax of 1d array type
is the data type
then there is array name
and after that size of array
and this is example of one dimensional
array
now coming to its memory representation
here we can see 2 7 4 8 1 6 are the
elements inside the memory blocks
and 0 1 2 3 4 5 are the indexes
so by using index we can easily access
the elements and once the array elements
are accessed a number of operations can
be performed
here area of 0 means 2 and arrow 1 means
7 and so on
as each element is of type int
that is 2 byte
that means the array occupies 12
contiguous bytes because each block
contain 2 byte and there are total 6
blocks
now coming to the two dimensional area
in this array each element is referred
by two indexes that is rows and columns
and they are stored in the form of
matrices
the first index shows a row of the
matrix and the second index shows the
column of the matrix
now moving to its memory representation
[Music]
as you can see this is a 2d array with 3
rows and 3 columns
and we can also say that these are
basically three 1d array containing
three blocks each
combined to form a 2d array in the form
of a matrix with size of three cross
three
the horizontal lines step its rows and
the vertical lines tap its columns
and we know that index starts from 0 so
first elements get stored at array 0 0
that is 0th row and 0 column
then second element is stored at array 0
1 that is 0 throw and column 1 and
likewise all the elements are stored in
the array
now coming to the multi-dimensional
array
[Music]
these are defined as area of arrays that
means each element of multi-dimensional
array is an array itself
they can have any number of dimensions
and it stores the data in tabular form
a two-dimensional array is also a
multi-dimensional array
and this is the syntax for a
here type is the data type of array then
array name is the name of the array and
size 1 size 2 up to so on size n are the
dimension of sizes after that this is
the basic example of a multi-dimensional
array
now coming to the next topic that is air
initialization
so there are two ways to initialize an
array in c plus
first is you can initialize an array
when you declare it by including the
initial values in braces after the
declaration
while declaring we could use curly
braces to set the values inside it
for example in this array of size 6 the
element 2 is at 0 index
5 is at 1 index 1 is at 2 index and so
on
if we don't mention the size of array
then the array will only be large enough
to hold the elements added within the
curly braces other than this we can set
the value after the declaration by
assigning the element to the array using
its index
like array of 0 equal to 5
here we are assigning 5 to index 0 and
arrow 1 equal to 7 here we are assigning
7 to index 1 and same goes for the array
of 2.
now let's do some examples on array to
understand them better we'll do these
examples on our code editor that is vs
code now we'll make a new file
and let's name that file as
array.cpp
array1 dot cpp
now we'll do a basic example in which we
have to print
the elements of array
so let's start first of all we'll write
the header file
[Music]
hash include iostream
now using namespace standard
[Music]
i will write into main
now we'll start by writing the data type
int
now we'll write the array name that is
let's say coupon
and
now the size of array
let's say 6
now
curly braces
now inside these curly braces will write
those elements
let's say 5
[Music]
1.
so these are those elements and this is
a
array declaration
now
here tint means the data type coupon is
the array name 6 is the size of array
and 5 8 7 3 9 1 are the elements of
array
now after that
we'll write the for loop with 4 keyword
now we'll initialize i
with 0
i less than 6 because it is the size of
array
now we'll increment i
now in this loop all we have to do is to
print this array
so how do we do that so let's do
c out
[Music]
and inside the bracket we'll write i
so here we have printed the array inside
the loop and we have put i inside the
array bracket
now the loop will run from i 0 to 6
and likewise all the elements from 5 to
1 will get printed so let's see
let's fly to learn this code
[Music]
so this is our output
so this is how we can print the elements
of an array
and if we want to print a particular
element from the array all we have to do
is to write the index number of that
element inside the bracket
let's say if we want to print 7
[Music]
all we have to do is to print its index
number that is 2.
now let's run this
see
777 it is because of the loop that from
i 0 to i 6 that is why it is getting
printed six times
now if we remove the loop and try to
print it then it will get print only one
time
let's see
here 7
and this is what we want to print
now let's do another example
[Music]
let's name this file
array2 dot cbd
now in this example all we have to do is
to do the sum of all the elements of the
error so let's start by writing our
header file
cache include iostream
[Music]
now using namespace std
now we'll write into main
now here first of all we'll declare a
variable sum and initialize it with zero
[Music]
now we'll declare another variable n
and n will depict the size of the array
so first of all in order to scan array
first of all we have to scan the size of
it
so we'll scan and
[Music]
now we'll declare the array
and inside the bracket we will mention n
because it is the size
[Music]
now we'll write for loop
and we will initialize with i equals 0
i less than
n which is the size of array and will
increment i plus plus
we are writing for loop here because we
want to scan the array and as in this
array there are more than one element so
that is why we need
for loops
so now we will scan the error
we'll write c in
the name of array
and inside the bracket we'll write i
now here we have written i inside the
brackets because we want to take input
of elements from i equal to 0 to n which
is the size of array
now
we'll take another for loop
now here we will write another for loop
in which we are initializing i from 0 to
n
and inside that for loop we will do the
sum of the array
so we'll write
equals to zero
[Music]
i less than n which is the size
now we will increment i plus plus
now inside this for loop
we'll do the code we'll do the logic of
adding the elements of the array
we'll write sum
as we know that we have already
initialized sum with zero we'll write
sum equals to sum
plus
array of phi
now for this statement sum equals to sum
area of i we are adding each value in
the array one by one into the sum which
is initially zero
when i equals to zero then the sum will
be equal to zero plus array of zero
and this sum will keep on getting stored
inside the variable sum
as our i increments our sum keeps on
storing the addition value
now
we'll print this sum
outside the loop
we'll write c out
and we'll write sum is
[Music]
now we'll write the sum variable
return
let me tell you return 0 is optional in
c plus
basically return value is exit status of
the program and 0 is considered as ok
in c plus compiler includes it
automatically but it's a good practice
here we forget to write the data type
[Music]
now we'll try to run it
so first of all we'll write the size
like
let's say 6
now the elements of the array
let's say 1
[Music]
and six
now we want to find the sum of these
elements
[Music]
sum is 21 let's recheck
1 plus 2 equals to 3 3 plus 3 equals 6
6 plus 4 10
10 plus 5 15 15 and 6 is 21 so this is
our right answer
so this is another basic example of
array
so after this we'll do one example of
two dimensional array also
so let's make a new file
and we'll write the header file
let's name this file as
array3.cpp
now name space standard
now we'll write into main
now we will declare a 2d array of 3 rows
and 3 columns with elements inside it
three rows
and second bracket will write three
columns
now we'll write the curly braces
and
another curly braces
this is the way to declare
a 2d array
now 2
9 let's say
now again curly braces
8 because we are creating a
matrix of 3 cross 3 that is why there
are total 9 elements inside the array
so now we will create a nested for loop
where the outer loop i which is for the
rows of matrix is initialized from 0 to
2.
we'll write
and i equal to 0
now i less than 3
i
plus plus increment
now we will write inner for loop j which
is for the column and we will initialize
it from 0 to 2 as well
we'll write 4
and j equals 0
j less than
3 j plus plus
now we will print the array
in the first bracket we will mention i
that is the number of rows and in the
second bracket we will mention j that is
number of columns
and in order to add space
we will add
space in the output
now
outside the bracket we will mention
and shift the elements to the next line
after that we'll write it in zero
so this is our output 541279138
in the matrix form that is why i have
used this space
to make the output look good
and this end l
so this is our output five four one two
seven nine one three eight
so this is how we can print the elements
of a multi-dimensional array or two
dimensional array
moving on to what is a pointer
pointer can be defined as a variable
that contains the address of another
variable
it basically stores the memory address
which means it points to an address of a
particular value
and like a regular variable
pointers have a data type also
now coming to reference and dereference
operators
reference operator or address of
operator is defined as that operator
which is used to get the address of the
variable
it can be easily obtained by preceding
the name of the variable with an
ampersand sign
now dereference operator
dereference operator basically returns
the content stored in the variable
pointed by the specified pointer for
example if we write asterisk a
then it will return the value of
variable pointed by a
now let's see how to declare and
initialize a pointer to declare a
pointer first of all we will write the
data type
after that we will write the name of the
variable with an asterisk sign
for example int asterisk sign a
float asterisk b
care asterisk c
suppose if we want to store the address
into a pointer
then we will write int that is the data
type
then ptr that is the name of the pointer
with an asterisk sign
equals to a variable a with ampersand
sign
which means
ptr will contain the address of the
variable a
now moving to a pointer arithmetic
c plus allows us to perform addition and
subtraction operations on pointers
a pointer is basically an address that
is it's a numeric value therefore
operations like addition subtraction can
easily be done on pointers
there are four types of arithmetic
operations that can be used in pointers
that is increment operator decrement
operator addition and subtraction
each time a pointer is incremented by 1
it points to the memory location of the
next element
but if the pointer is an integer pointer
its value on ptr plus plus would
increment by 4 bytes because of the size
of in data type
for example assume an integer pointer
with current value of 10.
now after the increment its value would
be 14 instead of 11 because int is of 4
bytes
now let's learn about pointers and
functions
like a normal variable has an address
similarly every function has an address
also and we can easily access the
function using its reference or address
only if we know the address of the
function
function pointers are similar to that of
normal pointers
when pointers are passed to the function
the address of actual arguments in the
calling function is copied into the
formal arguments of the called function
and this is the syntax for a declaration
of function pointer
here ent is the return type and
parenthesis around function pointer
tells the compiler that it is a 0.02
function
and after this
they are argument lists now
let's discuss pointers and arrays
arrays and pointers are very closely
related to each other and both of them
are objects
when an array gets declared the compiler
assigns a continuous block of memory so
that all the elements of an array can be
stored in the memory
and c plus treats the name of the array
as a pointer that contains the address
of first element
which is known as base address so
basically arrayname is the base address
of the array
and if we have to assign the address or
first element of array in a variable x
then instead of writing x equal to
ampersand array of 0
we can simply write the name of the
array only
now
moving to the last topic that is array
of pointers
like in array we can store similar type
of elements it is same in case of area
of pointers
but the only difference is instead of
storing the elements the address of
similar type of element is stored in
other words it stores the pointers which
point to the similar data type
and this is the syntax first is data
type
then name of array with an asterisk sign
then in the brackets it is the size of
array now
let's do some examples in our code
editor that is vs code if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
here we will do one example of pointer
to understand reference and dereference
operator
we will print the values of variable and
the address of that variable also and it
will give us an idea about reference and
dear reference operator
let's start
first of all we'll make a new file
and name this file as
pointer1.cpp
so first of all we will import the
header file
cache include iostream
now we will include namespace standard
after that we will make int main
and now we will declare a variable
val
and assign it a value let's say 105
now we will declare a pointer variable
ptr
now we will store the address of the
variable val
into the pointer variable
so we will write ptr equals
ampersand well
now
[Music]
we'll display a message
before
printing val variable will display a
message saying
value is
value of val is
now
let's see what is the value of ptr
for that we will have to print ptr also
and we'll write
value of
ptr
is
now we will print the pointer variable
ptr also
although the value of val and ptr would
be same but in order to check we will
print that also
so we'll write
see out
value of
specific ptr
is
now as we have printed variable val
ptr and
asterisk ptr
so now let's check
all these values
let's first of all write return 0
now let's check all these values
here we can see value of variable val is
and the value of ptr is this this is
actually the address
and
the value of
pointer variable ptr is 105
as we know that the value of vl and the
pointer variable is same
because we have assigned this value
the address of variable val to ptr
and then the dereference operator
as we know returns the actual content of
the variable so that is why the value of
variable val
gets printed when we print the pointer
variable ptr
and the address over here
is the address of the val variable which
we are assigning to the ptr
so that is why this address is getting
printed
now we will do another example
let's name it
pointer2.cpp
now we'll include the header files
hash included stream
after that
using namespace standard
so here we have an example of arithmetic
operations in c plus plus
so
first of all we'll write intent
now here we will take four variables and
two pointers
let's do it
and
num1
command num2
and
sum equals
zero
and in
sub
equals zero we'll initialize it with
zero
now i will declare the pointers
ptr2
so let's take input of the required
variables num1 and num2 and after that
we'll do some mathematic operations on
them
so let's just write
first we'll display a message
enter two numbers
enter
two numbers
now we'll take the input
after this we will store the address of
num1 and num2 into ptr1 and pdr2
respectively let's do it
ptr1
ampersand
num1
ptr2
ampersand num2
now we will increment pointer ptr1 and
ptr2
we'll do in a bracket
and we'll use the reference operator
also
ptr1 plus plus
the reference operator ptr2
plus plus
here we are using the reference operator
because we want to increment the value
only
and as we can see
we have used increment operator so by
incrementing ptr1 and ptr2
the values of num1 and num2 will
increment and after that we will print
those values
so let's do it
before printing we'll just print a
message
after increment
now we will print
ptr1
and line
now ptr2
now we will do the sum of these
incremented values so we will write sum
equals
the reference operator ptr 1
plus
the reference operator ptr2
now we will simply print it
we'll write addition
and we'll print some variable
which we have already initialized as
zero earlier
and we'll write end line
so this will give us the sum of the
incremented values of
num1 and m2
now let's talk about decrementing the
value of pointers using decrement
operator
here by using this operator the value of
the ptr1 and pta2 gets decremented so
let's start
you write
decrement ptr
minus minus
that is the decrement operator
now
ptr2
and s minus
now we will write
after decrement
the values of ptr1 and ptr2
so we'll display a message saying
after decrement
now we will print ptr1 and ptr2
this will display the values of ptr1 and
ptr2 after decrement
and at last we will find the subtraction
of two
so we'll write sub
decrement operator ptr1 minus decrement
operator ptr2
and
c out
will display first subtraction we'll
write subtraction
then we'll write the variable sub
let's see how it
before that i think we forgot to mention
the d reference operator
while printing
we have to mention this because we want
to print the values
the reference operator
and
let's put some space over
here now let's try
enter two numbers so let's say we'll
enter four
and five
as you can see we have entered four and
five after increment it becomes five and
six
and on addition it becomes eleven
after decrement it becomes four and five
again
then
four minus five that is equal to minus 1
so this is the right answer
and this is how it's done
this was the basic example of arithmetic
operations and pointers
now let's do another example
name this file as pointer 3 dot cpp
now we will include the header files
hash include
i stream
using namespace standard
now we'll write end main
now we will do an example of pointer and
arrays in which all we have to do is to
print an array with the help of pointers
so let's start
first of all we will declare a pointer
now we will declare an array
named
a rrey
and let's add some elements inside it
[Music]
sorry 20
i think these are seven elements
now we will assign array arr to pointer
ptr so we will write ptr
equals arr
after that we will run a loop from i
equal to 0 to i
less than 7 because we want white rate
array elements
so
let's write for loop
and i equals 0 i less than
i plus plus
now we will display
using
the reference operator with pointer
because we want to display the values
that is why we have used the reference
operator
now we will do
ptr
plus plus
we have used ptr plus plus because we
want the pointer to move to the next
position after each iteration
and endl will help to print the output
in the next line after each iteration
so after this we'll write
return 0.
and let's try to run it
i think there is some error
yeah
namespace
now let's again try to run it
instead of array we have used
arr hope it works now
here it is
27 9 4 6
5 17 20
7 9 4 6
so these are
our array elements which we want to
print
so this is how we can print the array
elements with the help of pointer
so these were some basic examples of
pointers in c plus let's go ahead and
have a look at what is memory management
memory management can be defined as a
process in which management of a
computer memory occurs
for example assigning memory to programs
variables etc in such a way that it
doesn't affect the overall performance
sometimes the computer's data can range
up to terabytes
so efficient use of memory is necessary
so that we can minimize the memory
wastage and boost up the performance
now
let's understand why we need memory
management in c plus
memory management is required so that
there will be no wastage of memory
and to make sure that allocation takes
place efficiently
during the declaration of an array there
are times when the correct memory is not
determined until runtime
and to avoid such cases we usually
declare array of maximum size
and because of this maximum size some
memory remains unused
for example let us suppose we have
declared an array of size 30 and after
declaring the array it turns out that we
only need space of 10 size
so the rest of the space is of no use or
we can say it will get wasted
to avoid such cases we use memory
allocation
so
let's understand memory allocation and d
allocation in z plus plus
other programming languages like java
python etc they don't need to allocate
memory dynamically
in c language we use the malloc or
catalog functions to allocate the memory
dynamically at runtime
and these functions are also supported
by c plus but in c plus allocation and
delocation is done manually in c plus
there are two operators that are used
for the allocation and d allocation of
memory that is new operator and delete
operator
so let's understand this new operator in
c plus
the new operator in c plus plus is used
for the dynamic memory allocation
it is used to allocate the memory at
runtime
the general syntax of new operator is
pointer variable which is the name of
the pointer equal to new which is a
keyword and data type is the type of the
pointer
the syntax for arrays is almost the same
but after the data type we have to write
the size inside the brackets which
specifies the number of elements in an
array
and here in the example we first of all
are declaring a pointer ptr of in data
type
after that we are dynamically allocating
the memory using new keyword
and at last we are assigning the value
75 to the allocated memory
coming to the delete operator
the delete operator in c plus is used
for the deallocation of memory
when we no longer need to use the
variable that means the memory is no
longer required
then we have to de-allocate or release
the memory using the delete operator
syntax for delete operator is
delete keyword with the name of the
pointer variable
the syntax for arrays is delete keyword
following the empty brackets and then
name a pointer variable
as we can see in the example once the
printing of value is done
we have deallocated the memory using the
delete operator
moving on to the advantages of new
operator
the new operator and delete operator can
be overloaded unlike the malloc function
next is return type of the new operator
is of the same type for which the memory
was allocated we don't need to use the
typecasting
third is
the new operator automatically computes
the size of data object we don't need to
use the size of operator
next is
new operator in c plus allows us to
initialize object while creating memory
space for them
so these were some advantages of the new
operator so now let's move on to our
code editor that is vs code to do some
examples on the new operator and delete
operator
here we will do an example using new and
delete operator in c plus that will
allocate the memory location for three
values and find their average
so first of all
let's
create a file and name this file as
mm1 dot cpp
mm means memory management so now first
of all we'll include the header files
hash include iostream
now using namespace standard
now we'll start within domain
okay
so first of all we will create three
pointer variables
so we'll start
hint
star ptr one
and
star ptr2
we are creating three pointer variables
because we have to find the sum of three
variables so that is why we have to
create three pointers also
and
now we have to store the sum of three
variables into some another variable so
we now will create the variable average
okay
now we will allocate the memory
dynamically
using the new keyword
so we'll write ptr1
equals
new
hint which is the data type
same we will do for ptr 2
equals new keyword
hint
here we are allocating the memory
dynamically with the help of new keyword
new
and
sorry time is there
now we will print the value that is
stored in the memory
but before doing that
as we have allocated the memory so now
we will take the input from the users
of those three variables
of which we have to find the average off
so
we'll display
enter first number
after displaying this
we'll take the input from the user
write c in
and
using the d reference operator
write ptr1
here we are taking the input from the
user for the first memory location
now we'll take the input of the second
number from the user
for that we have to
print the message again
enter the second number
yeah
now
we'll take the input using the d
reference operator
with the pointer
now same goes for the third one
enter the
third number
d reference operator ptr3
as we have taken all the three numbers
from the user now all we have to do
is to find the average of these three
numbers as we know that d reference
operator will point to the variable
so
that is how we'll get the access for the
variable
now we'll write
the variable avg that is average
we know that the reference operator will
display the value
that is pointer pointing at
so
we are actually adding the values
ptr1
plus dereference operator ptr2
plus dereference operator ptr3
divided by 3
this is how we can find the average
after that
all we have to do is to print the
average
so
we'll write
average is
avg that is the variable
as the result is getting stored in this
variable avg so we'll print that
variable
and once everything is done once the
printing is
then we have to de-allocate the memory
and
we will de-allocate the memory by
writing delete
ptr1
we have to do this for all of these
three pointers delete ptr two
because we have allocated the memory for
all of these three pointers so that is
why we have to deallocate for each one
of them
okay
now
everything is done and let's try to run
this
here we can see enter the first number
so
[Music]
let's say
five
we have to find the average of three
numbers so we'll select the easy number
to
check whether it is right or wrong
then we'll write 5 again
now we'll write 2
as we know that 5 plus 5 equals 10
plus 2 equals 12
and
the average of 12 is four yeah three
fours at 12. so this is the correct
output
so
first of all we have allocated the
memory over here dynamically then we
have deallocated the memory using delete
ptr1 ptr2 and ptr3
so this is how it's done
so let's do one another example
let's name this as
mm2.cpp
okay
we'll write mm4 dot cpp
i think two and three are already taken
so we'll start with hash include
iostream hash
include
iostream
then we'll write
using namespace standard
so in this question we'll simply enter
the elements of the array and then we
will display those elements
but we will use new operator and delete
operator in this question
so let's start first of all we'll write
int main
inside int main first of all we'll write
the variable
size we have declared the variable size
and this variable size is the size of
the array
which we will take as an input from the
user
so
first of all
will display
enter the size
now we'll take the input
size
after that we will declare a pointer
variable
ptr
all right
now here we will allocate the memory for
the complete array so we'll write
ptr
new keyword
int
which is the data type and
here size
okay here we are allocating the memory
for the complete array of size that we
will enter
okay now
now we will display
the message saying that enter the
elements
as we have allocated the memory
all we have to do is to enter the
elements
we'll use a for loop
so we'll start with i equals 0 i less
than size
i plus plus
now
we'll write
element
and after this we'll take the input from
the user
for the elements of the array so we'll
write c in
now just like carries we can do it for
the pointer as well we can write ptr
and just like it is
inside the bracket i
and we can do
it for the output as well
so here we are taking the input of the
elements from the users
now
we have to display those elements
so for that first of all we will display
a message
elements that you
have
entered
now we'll use for loop again
and i equals 0
i less than size
i plus plus
now
we'll
print those elements so first of all
we'll write
element
now
ptr
like just we
did earlier ptri
and end line
so that the output looks good
now everything is done we have allocated
the memory then we have taken the input
from the user and displayed the output
now all we have to do is to delete the
operator
so i'll write
delete
then empty brackets
ptr
all right
now everything is done
we have allocated the memory and here we
are deleting the allocated memory
okay
now let's try to run this
here we can see enter the size let's say
now enter the elements
and
here is the output elements that you
have
entered three six
five seven
that is right but
it is not looking good
let's use slash and over here
and now let's again try to run this
enter the size
now
4 seven
nine
uh here is the space between them now it
is looking good enter elements that you
have entered are
two four seven nine
so this is how it's done we have
allocated the memory
to an array of size
of size variable
then we have entered the elements
then we have displayed those elements
and at last we have de-allocated the
memory using delete operator
so these are few examples on memory
management c plus memory management you
can try some more examples on them let's
go ahead and have a look at why do we
need classes
to understand this we need to know that
c plus plus is an object-oriented
language and it also introduces the
concept of real-world entities
so in order to describe the real-world
entities we need two things
that is characteristics and functions
and a class is a mechanism of binding
these two methods together in a single
unit
also class has its own members like
functions variables constructors
destructors etc
which are commonly used in c plus plus
and class has an important role in the
concept of inheritance as well
now let's understand what is a class
classes are one of the most important
features of c plus plus that leads to
object oriented programming
it represents the set of properties that
are common among all the objects of same
type
a class basically represents a group of
similar objects which holds its own data
members and member function together
and this is the basic syntax of a class
first is class keyword which is used to
create class then after that we will
write the name of the class
then inside the name of the class there
is access specifier that can be private
public or protected
after that there is data members that is
the variables and then the member
functions and also class body must be
surrounded with braces
now let's discuss access modifiers it
basically grant permission or set the
restriction for data members of the
class
access modifiers in a class are used to
provide accessibility to the class
member
for example
in a school teachers are allowed to see
the question papers before the exams but
the students are not allowed to do so
anyone other than teachers cannot access
those questions
now
we can relate these teachers to data
members of class
which have access and students are
outside functions that do not have the
access
so there are three types of access
modifiers
private public and protected
private members can only be accessed
from within the class that means
outside data members and member
functions cannot access it
public as the name suggests it can be
accessed from within the class and from
outside the class as well
protected members can be accessed from
within the class but cannot be accessed
from outside the class
but with the help of friend function it
can be accessed from outside the class
as well
now let's learn about object of a class
an object is an instance of a class it
is a real word entity that contains
state and behavior
when we create an object of a class then
the memory is allocated and no memory
allocation occurs when class is defined
and we can create as many objects of a
class as we need
in this example state is the class and
st is the object name or reference
variable
so this is how an object is created
now coming to member functions
member functions are also known as
methods
these are as much as part of the class
as the member variables
these member functions can be invoked by
sending messages through an instance of
a class
with the help of dot operator
for example if the name of the object is
obj and we want to access a function
named sum then it will be obj.sum
here obj is the name of the object and
sum is the name of the function
now let's learn about constructors
constructors can be defined as a special
type of method
that is invoked automatically whenever
an object is created
its main use is to initialize objects
it doesn't have any return type and a
constructor has the same name as that of
the class
and
it is of two types parameterized and
non-parameterized
the syntax for parameterized constructor
is class name which is a constructor
name and then arguments inside the
bracket
in non-parameterized constructor the
syntax is class name
with empty brackets as there are no
parameters in non-parameterized
constructors
now
after constructor
let's discuss the destructor also
destructor as the name suggests is also
a special method
that destroys or destructs the object as
soon as the scope of the object ends
and it is automatically invoked when the
object goes out of the scope
its name is same as that of the class
but with the tilde sign
here is the syntax of destructor
tilde sign
with constructor name or class name and
then empty brackets
now to do some examples on classes let's
move on to our code editor that is vs
code
now here we will make a new file
and let's name this file as
class.cpp
now here we will do a program in which
we will make a class and inside that
class we will make some functions and
with the help of objects of that class
we will call those functions
so let's start
first of all we'll mention the header
files hash include
iostream
now
using namespace standard
now let's
make a class
and with a class keyword
and name this class as let's say
franchise
now here don't forget to mention the
semicolon
now
here we will write the access modifier
that is public
now we will mention those functions
let's say void
let's name this function as kfc
now inside this function
we will
print
something like let's say
we have the best chicken
after this we'll write endl
now we'll make another function named
burger king
as we know that these two are
famous franchise so that is why we have
put this under class for franchise
now let's
print here
we have the best burgers
now we'll try to
print these two functions with the help
of object that are made from the class
franchise
so what we'll do is
we'll write end main
after the franchise class we'll write
int main and inside this class
we'll make an object
of class franchise
franchise is the class name fran is the
object name
now
all we have to do is the calling
we'll call the function kfc and we'll
call the function burger king with the
help of fran object
so let's do this
friend
dot operator
k fc
that is the function name
after that we'll write fran
dot
burger king
return 0
now let's try to run this one
here it is actually i have run it twice
so that is why it is getting printed
twice
we have the best chicken we have the
best burgers that is what we want to
print
first here friend dot kfc
called this void kfc inside this class
franchise after that
friend.burger king called this function
burger king
so that is why they have printed cereal
wise we have the best chicken we have
the best burgers
after this we'll do another example
so let's do this
first of all we will name this file
class
class2.cpp
ok i think it already exists
we have to name it something else
okay now we will write
the header files
hash include iostream
now using
namespace standard
in this example we will try to access a
private variable
as we know that it can only be accessed
from within the class but it can be done
with the help of set getter methods
so let's start
first of all we'll write
int main
now we'll
[Music]
make an object
for that we have to write the class name
which is
billboard
we'll make this class afterwards
first of all we'll write
the
class name after that we'll write object
let's name the object bill
billboard is class name bill is the
object name
now we will call
a particular method
or a function
which we call setter method we will
write
bill
dot
will name that setter method as set
title
basically this
function will access
or assign the value to the private
variable which we were talking about
so we'll write here
let's say top
5 songs
of
we want this title to be written on the
billboard
now we will write the getter method
basically the setter method or set title
method will set or assign the value of
to the private variable and get method
or get title method will return that
value from there
so we'll write
bill dot
get
title
now because we want to print it so that
is why we'll write it
in c out
okay
now after that we'll write return zero
now we will make the class billboard
class keyword
billboard
after that
bracket starts
now we will write
private
because we want
the variable to private
so
the data type string
and the variable is title
now this variable is private and we want
to assign the value to this variable
which is not possible because they are
not of the same class but we will do
that with the help of settle getter
method
so let's do that
now we will write public
because we want our functions to be
public
now
void that is the data type
set title
and inside the bracket will
write the variable
now this method is taking this very this
parameter x so we will assign this
parameter x to the
private variable
let's do that
title that is the private variable
x
now
we will write another method
named get title
there are no parentheses in get title
method because
this method is only returning the value
so we'll write
return
title
now get title function or method is
returning the value of private variable
title
so here what happening is here the
function set title which is public is
taking a parameter x and is assigning to
the title variable
so the message will get assigned to the
title variable
now get title function is returning the
value of private variable title
which is getting called in the main
function
one more thing we forgot to
put semicolon over here
and
we get title cannot be void
because it is returning
it would be string
because it is returning some value
now
so basically
bill dot set title in the main function
will set the value or assign the value
to the private variable and bill dot get
title will return the value of that
private variable which will get printed
so now let's try to run this
[Music]
top 5 songs of 2020. here we can see
it is getting printed
so this is how we can do that we can
access the private variable using setter
and getter method
now let's do another example
let's name this as
class 4 dot cpp
now here we will do the same example but
we will do it with the help of
constructors
so let's continue first of all we'll
write
hash include iostream
after that
using namespace standard
now here first of all we'll write int
main
now
we'll name the class we'll write the
name of the class that is billboard
and we'll make the object of it
as we have done previously like bill
now
we'll make
a constructor of this object
and we'll pass the parameters
we'll pass the string
as top 3
songs
of 2020
as we are passing this string to the
constructor that means the constructor
is parameterized constructor
and now
we'll write
bill
dot
get
title
here we are writing this because
function this function is returning the
value of private variable title so that
is why we have to write it
and we'll print it actually
c out
return 0
now let's do the other thing
as we have done previously we'll write
class
billboard we are making this class
and inside this class we are making
the variable private
string title is private
now we'll write public access modifier
now here we will write the constructor
in which we were passing the string from
the main function
so we will write the name of the
constructor
as you all know the name of the
constructor is same as that of the class
so it would be
billboard
and
the parameter is
b
that parameters which we are passing
from the main function is getting stored
in b
now inside this constructor will call
the method set title
so we'll write set
title
we are passing the same string
to the set title method
now
we will make this method
set title we'll write
void
set title
string a
so actually what is happening
we have passed the string name top three
songs of 2020 to the constructor
the constructor is further calling to
the method or function named set title
and is passing that string to the same
function
now that function is set title and now
we will assign that string to the
private variable title
so let's write
title equals
a
a is that string
now as we have done previously we will
write void
get
title
now get title function is used for
returning the value of private variable
as we know so we'll write
string actually
string
get title
return
title
semicolon
now let's try to run it
i think something is wrong
here capital s we have written
let's make it correct
now let's try to run again
here we can see top three songs of 2020
so this is how we can print with the
help of constructor
this was the same example as that of the
previous one but to understand
constructors we have done this with the
help of constructors and we get the
right output
so after this we'll do the example of
destructors
okay let's name this
as class
6. dot cpp
now let's write the header files
hash include
iostream
using namespace standard
now we'll start with int main
so first of all we will write the class
name that is gambit
to access the class we need to have an
instance or object of class
here the name of the object is gam
after this we will call a function
display
so we will write
gam dot display
return 0
now let me tell you what is happening
so as we declared this object
constructor will be called that is
gambit and the message inside the
constructor will be printed
after the constructor gets completed we
will return back to the main
now we have game dot display which is
used to call display function inside the
gambit class
so after this we will write the class
let's make it
class keyword
gambit
now we'll write
public access modifier
now we'll write the constructor
and inside the constructor will display
the message
we'll write
hello
hello there
i am constructor
i am in constructor
now here we will write the destructor
gambit
and inside the
destructor we will print the message
just to indicate that we are in the
destructor
hello there
i am in destructor
semicolon
but before that we have to
write the function display also so we'll
write
void
display
and we'll print the message
let's say hello
and l
now let's try to understand this again
as the object is declared constructed
will be called that is gambit and the
message inside the constructor will be
printed
after the constructor gets completed we
will return back to the main
now we have gam dot display
which is used to call display function
inside the gambit class
so hello will be printed
now as we can see the program has
finished the execution now the
destructor will be called and hello i am
destructor will be printed
as we know destructor destroys the
object at as the scope of the object
ends so after the scope of the object
ends hello i am in destructor gets
printed in the last
so
now let's try to run this
here we can see hello there i'm in
constructor
then hello is printed then hello there i
mean destructor is printed as we have
thought
destructor is getting printed in the
last because as we know that when the
scope ends the destructor is called
so these were some basic examples of
classes in c plus now
let's move on to why oops
well there were some limitations in
earlier approaches to programming and
oops help to fill those gaps
in object oriented programming it is
easy to maintain the code with the help
of classes and objects
and with the help of inheritance there
is code reusability that is we don't
have to write the same code again and
again which increases the simplicity of
the program
now let's understand what is object
oriented programming
object oriented programming is a
programming pattern where the programs
are structured around objects rather
than logic and functions
in other words we basically focus on
objects that are required to be
manipulated instead of logic
for example let us suppose we have made
blueprint of a mole then that blueprint
will be a plan that explains what
properties the mall should have and how
it should look like etc
but it is just a blueprint of the mall
we cannot go inside it physically as of
now
now the constructors will go through the
blueprint and they will construct them
all and they can make as many malls as
they want with the help of that
blueprint and each mall can have its own
different shops and showrooms
in this case blueprint is the class
the mall is the object and the show ups
and showrooms inside the malls are data
stored in the object's properties
and these are some basic concepts of
hoops
first is classes then objects then data
abstraction and encapsulation then there
is inheritance polymorphism dynamic
binding and message passing we will
learn about these concepts later first
we will discuss the difference between
oops versus procedural programming
procedural programming follows top down
approach here top down approach means
fragmenting a bigger complication into
smaller chunks
oops follows bottom-up approach and
bottom-up approach means piecing
together smaller tasks to give rise to
complex tasks
in procedural programming overloading is
not possible
in oops overloading can be done
in procedural oriented programming there
are no access specifiers in oop
they have access specifiers like private
protected public
procedural oriented programming is less
secure
oops is more secure because of the
concepts like abstraction and
encapsulation which are used for data
hiding
now
let's learn the basic concepts of oops
first is class can be defined as
collection of objects it is a logical
entity
then there is object
it is defined as an entity that has
state and behavior or in other words
anything that exists physically in the
world is called an object
inheritance can be defined as when one
object acquires properties and behavior
from its parent class
it provides code usability
polymorphism polymorphism is a
combination of two words poly which
means many and morphs which means forms
it is basically an ability to exist in
more than one form
next is abstraction
hiding the internal details and showing
the functionality to the user is called
abstraction
then encapsulation encapsulation is the
binding of code and data together into a
single unit
in dynamic binding
dynamic binding is the method called at
runtime that means which code will
execute is unknown until the program
runs
then there is message passing
it is basically a communication that
exists between the objects
as we have gone through some concepts of
oops
now let's discuss some benefits of oops
in oops code can easily be reused with
the help of inheritance and object
we don't need to write the same code
over and over
second is with the help of abstraction
and encapsulation certain parts of
program can be hidden and it helps to
make a secure system
third is maintaining and modification of
code is easy in object oriented
programming
now to do some examples on concepts of
oops let's move on to our code editor
that is vs code
now here we will do a program of
inheritance in which we will make a
parent class and a child class and we
will call the attributes using object of
child class
so let's get started first of all
let's name the file
oop
dot cpp
okay so first of all we'll add the
header files
hash include
iostream
now adding namespace standard
now we will write into main
so we want to create the object of side
class so first of all we'll write the
name of class child that is child
let's put c capital
child and now the name of the object ch
so now we will call the attributes using
this object
so we'll write first of all
display it so we'll write c out
ch
dot
name
which is the attribute
we will declare it later
so basically we want to write both the
names of both the classes together so
that is why
we are doing like this we'll write name
two
name one will be the attribute of the
parent class and name two will be the
attribute of child class
so after that we'll write
return zero
now
we'll make the parent class and the
child class so first of all let's write
class
parent we'll name it as parent
then
we'll write public access specifier
string
is the data type
name
one
let's write
harley
okay now
it is mandatory to write the semicolon
at the end of the class
now
we'll write the derived class that is
child
we will write the column symbol
then we will write public
name of the parent class that is parent
so here we are writing
the child class is derived from the
parent class
now
within the bracket we'll
write public
then string the data type
name to
we'll write ha davidson
it's a popular bike brand harley
davidson
so
now we'll write the semicolon over here
now we'll try to run this
[Music]
as you can see harley davidson
here harla is from the parent class and
davidson is from the child class
so as we can see that we are calling
from the object of child class and still
we are able to access the attribute of
parent class
so this shows that the child class
inherits attributes or properties from
the parent class
now as we have done one example of
inheritance
so now let's do one example of
polymorphism also
let's name it oop
one dot cpp
first of all we'll include the header
files
flash include iostream
stream
now we'll write using namespace standard
after that we'll write int main
now here we will do an example of
polymorphism in which we will make a
base class and its derived classes and
inside these classes we will override a
function which is common in all of these
classes
so let's start
first of all we'll write the name of the
parent class or base class
animal
and will make an object a
after that we'll write the name of the
child class jita
and its object name is c let's say
now another derived class dolphin
and we'll name the object as d
now while making these classes we'll
write a function name speed in all of
these classes inside all of these
classes and now in order to override
that function we'll call them
so
first of all we'll call it by the object
of animal that is a
a dot
speed
now c dot
this is the object of cheetah class
now
d dot
speed
after that we'll write return zero
now let's make these classes
first of all we will make the animal
class that is the base class
animal now we'll write the access
specifier public
now we'll write the function
void that is the data type speed
now we will
display a message inside this function
let's say
it displays who is more faster
who
is more
faster
okay
now
we'll put a semicolon in the end
now we will make a derived class that is
dolphin
we write class
child of
animal
class
okay so now inside this class
we'll write public
and will make the same function speed
and will display a message
saying
as this class is of dolphin so
we'll write
i'm faster
in
water
we'll put semicolon
now we'll make
another child's class
class
cheetah
okay c is capital cheetah
public
animal
now here we will write
public access specifier
and we'll write the same function wide
speed
and over here will display a message
saying that
i am
faster on the ground
semicolon
so now as we can see that a dot speed is
calling this speed function
in animal class
c dot speed is calling this
cheetah function
in cheetah class
and d dot speed
d dot speed is calling the dolphin
speed function in dolphin class
okay so now let's try to run this
[Music]
okay the output is here but it is not
in very good form so
let's put slash n in the end
okay
slash and
slash n
okay
here it is
so first who is faster is displayed then
i am faster on the ground
then i am faster in water
is displayed
so as we know that first of all we have
called
the animal class so that is why who is
more faster is displayed after that we
have called the cheetah class and
cheetah says that i'm faster on the
ground then dolphin class then dolphin
says i am faster in water
so
here we can see that each of the class
have its different implementation for
the same function that is speed
and this is how polymorphism allows us
to do a single action in variety of ways
okay now let's do one example of
abstraction
let's name it as
oop
three dot cpp
first of all we'll include the header
files we'll write hash
include iostream
now we'll write the namespace standard
using namespace
std
now as we know abstraction helps in data
hiding so in this program we will make a
variable named coupon as private and
with the help of set coupon function we
will try to assign some value to the
coupon variable
and after that we will display it
so let's start
first of all we'll write int main
now we'll write the name of the class
that is trade fair
trade
fair
and now the name of the object t
now with the help of this object we will
call a function named
set
coupon
i would say coupons
we'll pass 50 as an argument to this
function
now
we'll display
a message
coupon
and after that
we will call getcoupon method in order
to display the number of coupons
so we'll write t dot
get
coupons
and
brackets
done
after that we'll write return 0
now let's make the class and the
functions
so let's start first of all
we'll
write class
trade fair
now we'll write an access specifier
private
and
i private
now
we will declare a variable coupon
and as i've already told you we will
make this variable as private so that is
why we have used this access specifier
as private
now
after that we will
write public
access specifier
to write a function
that is set coupons
set
coupons
and the parameter is c as we know that
we have passed 50 to this
parameter
so
now
we will write
the private variable coupon
equals c
so here we are basically assigning
the value of c to the coupon that is we
are assigning 50 to coupon
variable
now
after that
we will make another function
and
we'll put its data type as int because
it is returning something
so
we'll write and get coupon
and we will return
variable coupon
now as the class ends we will write
semicolon
now let's try to run this code
there is some error
okay we haven't tried s over here
now let's again try to run it
open
as i have told you
so here we have assigned 50 to
this function
and
the variable c is assigning
50 to the variable coupon
now after that we have used getcoupon
function to return the value of coupon
and that is why it is getting displayed
over here
so
we got our answer that is coupon 50.
and as you can see that in this example
we are not
allowed to access the variable coupon
but still somehow we have managed to do
that with the help of some functions
so this is an example of abstraction
and
it helps to increase the security of the
program
so this were these were some basic
examples
of oops in c plus let's go ahead and
have a look at what is operator
overloading
operator overloading is a special case
of polymorphism in which the operator is
overloaded to provide special meaning to
the user defined data type
basically it adds some features or
redefines the functionality of already
existing operators
for example let us suppose we have three
objects of same class namely a b c
and c equals a minus b
now here we can redefine how minus
operator works and we can write
c equals a minus b instead of writing c
equals to a dot subtract b
and this is the general syntax of
operator overloading
first is the return type of the function
after that operator is the keyword then
symbol is the operator we want to
overload
then the arguments are those which are
passed to the function
now let's move on to the non
overloadable operators
there are some operators in c plus plus
that cannot be overloaded because it is
not synthetically possible to overload
them
first is the dot operator the next is
scope resolution operator and third is
pointer to member operator and at last
we have ternary operator
coming to the next topic that is types
of operator overloading in c plus plus
so there are two types of operator
overloading that is unary operator
overloading and binary operator
overloading
first is unary operator overloading
it is defined as an operator which
contains only one operand or works on
only one operand
increment operator and decrement
operator are examples of it
there are two ways to do operator
overloading that is from the class
function and the friend function
its syntax using class function is the
return type
operator keyword then the symbol and the
brackets but if we are doing postfix in
the function then we have to write the
data type inside the brackets
syntax using friend function is
friend keyword return type then operator
keyword after that symbol and in case of
friend function we have to pass an
argument
next is
binary operator overloading
an operator which contains two operands
or works with two operands is called
binary operator overloading addition
subtraction multiplication are examples
of binary operator overloading
syntax using class function is return
type then operator keyword then the
symbol and then we have to pass an
argument inside the brackets
and syntax using front function is
friend keyword then the return type
after that operator keyword and then the
symbol and in case of friend function we
can pass two arguments
now we will do one example of unity
operator overloading in which we will
increment the value of the variable with
the help of operator overloading
so now let's move on to our code editor
that is vs code
so here first of all we'll make a new
file
and name that file as
operator
dot cpp
now first of all we write the header
files hash include
iostream
now we'll write the namespace standard
now we'll start with int main
and inside intmin first of all we'll
write the name of the class that is
increase
and its object inc
now we will call the void operator
increment function
so we will write
plus plus i and c
here when we write plus plus i and c
then function void operator plus plus
will be called
which we will make later
so as of now first of all we
write i and c dot display in order to
display the output
we are calling the display function over
here
now after that we'll write return zero
now we'll make the class
so we'll write
class
increase which is the name of the class
now we'll use the access specifier
private
and we'll write the variable
int
value
now we'll write another access specifier
public
and now we will make the constructor
because we have created the object inc
so that is why a constructor is called
and we are making it
increase
and inside the constructor we have given
the value
10 to the variable
now
plus plus inc is calling the void
operator plus plus function so we'll
write that function
void
operator
increment
which is the symbol
now
value equals
value plus 5 because we are incrementing
the variable with five so we'll write
value equals value plus five
now after that we have to display the
value variable so we will write
void
display
because we have already called over here
inc dot display so
now we will write inside
c out
we'll write the message value
is
now the variable value
and endl
after the class we have to use the
semicolon now let's try to run this
here
is our output value is 15.
previously the value was 10 then on
increment its value gets 15 which is the
right output
so
here first of all we have created an
object and constructor is called and
inside the constructor we have
initialized value with 10.
then with the help of object inc that is
when we are using plus plus inc then we
are calling the void operator function
which is increasing the value of the
variable by 5 and then we are displaying
it with the help of display function
and one more thing guys in case of
postfix that is in case of inc plus we
have to write the data type inside the
void operator function
that is over here
now let's do another example for binary
operator overloading
so let's name this
operator
2 dot cpp
now here we will do one example of
binary operator overloading in which we
will add two complex numbers
so let's start
first of all
let's make the header files
hash include iostream
now using namespace standard
now we'll write int main
okay now first of all we will write the
name of the class that is complex
so we'll write
complex
and then
the objects like com1
com2
res
we have created three object
now we will
write a message
because we have to take the input from
the user so first of all we will write a
message
enter first complex number
because we have to add two complex
numbers
so first of all we'll
take the input of the first one
that is
slashing
okay now
we have to
write com1 dot input input is the name
of the function
which we will be creating afterwards
then
c out
enter second complex number
that is
now we'll write slash n
okay
now after
this we have to write the
semicolon and we'll write com2
dot input
these input function will take the input
of complex numbers from the user we will
declare them later we will make them
later
okay now
we will now here we will do an operation
with the help of plus operator function
so we will write
res equals
com1
plus com2
this function call from com1 will go to
the complex of operator plus function
and com2 will be passed to the argument
obj
and the result will be stored in
variable res
okay now we will
call another function output
in order to display the output
rest.output after that we'll write
return 0
now we will make the class complex
we'll write
class
complex
we'll write the access specifier private
and the variables int real
and end
image that is imaginary because we know
in complex number there is a real part
and imaginary part
okay now we'll write public access
specifier
and now we will write the function input
in order to take the input from the user
void input
now first of all we have to display a
message we will write enter real
imaginary parts respectively
okay
now we will write
c in because we have to take the input
and the variable name real
and imaginary
now we will write the overloading
function we'll write the return type
that is the complex
then operator keyword
then symbol
then
argument
complex
obj
okay now
we will write
complex
temp
so here we have created the data type
temp of complex class
we'll make it a capital c
okay now we will write
temp dot real equals to real plus
obj.trial so we'll write temp
dot
real
equals to
real plus
obj
dot real
the plus operator over here will add the
real part of the number to the real part
of another number
and similarly we'll do it for the
imaginary part
right temp dot
imaginary
equals
imaginary plus
obj
dot
imaginary
and
and then the value of the variable temp
is returned so we'll write
return
temp
the value was stored in temp so that is
why we have returned temp
now we will make the output function
we'll write
wide
output
right output is
variable real
then
we'll write plus
then imaginary
and then i because this is the syntax
for
complex number
okay
now we have to put the semicolon over
here
as the value of temp is returned
now the result is stored in variable res
and then we will print the output using
the output function this is the output
function
and
the value is stored in dress and then we
are printing the output using the output
function
com1 over here is getting passed to the
complex of operator plus function and
com2 is getting passed to the argument
obj
and the result is getting stored in res
now let's try to run this code
the first complex number let's say
plus 2 iota so we will write 2 and 2
and then enter second complex number
that is enter real and imaginary parts
respectively now we have to write the
real and imaginary parts of the second
complex number so we'll write
plus
6 iota
so the output is
6 plus 8 iota 2 plus 4 equals 6 and 2
plus 6 equals to 8 so this is our
correct output we are basically adding
two complex numbers with the help of
binary operator overloading
so this is how it is done
so these were some important examples of
operator overloading moving on to why we
use vectors in c plus
vectors are used when we are not sure
about the size of data like in case of
arrays we have to guess the size of the
data first because it is not possible to
resize it later
but in case of vectors we don't have to
set the size of vector and it is
resizable that is why it is more
preferable for dynamic elements
and it also has some inbuilt functions
like pushback size empty etc which helps
in dealing with data values
now let's understand what is a vector
vectors are array-like containers that
is used to store data and the data is
stored in contiguous storage locations
but unlike arrays its size can be
changed automatically depending on the
number of elements and it is not
necessary to mention the size of vector
while declaring it
now
let's have a look at the syntax here
inside the angle brackets
this is the data type of the vector it
can be string end float etc and v2 v1 v3
are the names of the vectors
respectively
now let's understand the member
functions of vectors
a vector container has three types of
member functions that is modifiers
iterators and capacity
so let's understand these functions in
detail
first is modifiers
these are those functions
that are used to modify data elements
for example first is pushback function
this function is used to add a new
element to the end of the vector
next is pop back
this function
deletes the last element of the vector
then there is insert function it is used
to insert a new element at a specified
position
in this function there are two
parameters
first parameter specifies the position
and second specifies the value
after that erase function raise function
is used to remove the elements at a
certain position or to remove a range of
elements
either you can write the position of the
element you want to remove inside the
bracket or you can write starting
position and ending position of the
range of elements inside it
next is swap function
this function is used to swap the
contents or elements between two vectors
and if there are two vectors named v1
and v2
that we want to swap then its syntax
would be v1 dot swap v2
then there is a sine function this
function is used to assign values to the
vector
in this function there are two
parameters first one specifies number of
values to be assigned and second
represents the value that is to be
assigned
last is clear function this function is
used to remove all the elements from the
vector
now moving on to iterator functions
these are those functions that helps in
iterating across the elements first is
begin function it basically returns the
iterator pointing to the beginning of
the vector
the next is and function
this function returns the iterator
pointing to the end of the vector
now coming to capacity functions
these functions that lie under capacity
are associated with size
so first is size function
this function returns the number of
elements in the vector
next is max size function this function
returns the maximum size that a vector
can hold
then there is resize function this
function changes the size of the
container
and inside the brackets a number n is
mentioned
if n is less than the size of container
then content is reduced by removing
extra elements
but if n is greater than the size of the
container then extra elements are added
at the end
so that it reaches the size of n
after that capacity function
this function returns the size that is
currently allocated to the vector
container
at last there is empty function
which checks whether the vector is empty
or not
if it returns true then it is empty and
if false then it is not empty
now to understand these vector functions
in a better way
let's do some examples of these vector
functions in our code editor that is vs
code
so first of all let's make a new
file and name this file
vector.cpp
now first of all we will write the
header file
that is
hash include
iostream
now we will write the header file
hash
include
vector
this is the header file for vector
because we are doing some examples on
vectors so that is why we have to use it
now
we'll write the name space standard
using
namespace
std
now we'll start with int main
now first of all we'll define the vector
so we'll write
vector
and inside the angle bracket we'll write
int which is the data type
now the name of the vector
will write n
now first of all we'll see the
functionality of assign function
as we know that assign basically puts
the value at positions
so we will write
and
dot
assign
now first of all
we'll write the number of
values
like 9 is the number of values
after that in the second parameter we'll
write the value
here it means that we are putting 1 to 9
positions in the vector
that is we are assigning 1 to 9
positions
now in order to print this
first of all we will
display a message
saying
the contents are
now in order to print these contents
basically we have to
write a for loop
we'll write int a
equals zero
we'll initialize it from zero then
a less than
and dot size
this is the size function it basically
returns the number of elements
now
a plus plus
will increment
we have to now print this
we have to write like an array
in order to print all the elements
we'll write
n
and inside the bracket a
now we'll leave some space
we'll write endl
we wrote ndl over here in order to
insert a new line
now after that
we'll see the functionality of one
another function that is pushback
and we know that pushback functions adds
an element at the end of the vector so
we will write n dot
push back
and then the element which we want to
add
like let's say 2
now
we have to display this last element
also
so in order to display this we will
store the size of vector in some
variable
and then we will print the last element
so we will write
int
and no
this is the variable name
then we will write
and dot
size
here we are storing the size of the
vector in some variable and no
now
we will display
last element
we'll display the message saying last
element
and then we will
print the last element and as we know in
order to print the last element we have
to print
the n minus one element
so we will write n bracket
and no minus one
here we are writing
n bracket
and no minus 1
this will print the last element
after that we'll write endl
now after that
we will
see another function that is pop back it
basically removes the last element so
we'll write n
pop underscore back
so this function will remove the last
element that we have added that is 2
so we need to print this also
so we'll write
first of all we'll display a message
now the contents are
now we again write the for loop
as we have done previously
we'll write int a equals 0
a
less than
and dot size
a plus plus
now we will again print
in the form of array
sorry
and
and inside the bracket we will write a
then in order to give some space we'll
write this
after this we'll write handle
to add one new line
so firstly we displayed the contents
then we added one element at the end and
then displayed that element after that
we have removed that element with the
help of pop back function
as you have noticed that we are just
doing the functions of modifiers yet so
in this example we will cover some
functions of modifiers only then in the
next examples we will do for iterator
functions and then for the capacity
function
so now let's do the functionality of
insert function
as we know that insert function is used
to add an element at a specified
position
so we will write
n dot
insert
and dot begin
it will point to the first element
then
seven
as we know that the first parameter
specifies position and the second
specifies the value
so n dot begin will point to the first
position
and 7 is the value
so now we will print it also
we'll write
first element
is
then we will write
display the first element
then we'll write endl
now we will use the function
clear
to remove all the elements we'll write n
dot c l e a r clear
and then in order to check
we will write n dot size so first of all
we'll write now
the size is
and in order to check
whether it is whether all the elements
are removed or not
we'll write and dot size
it will display the size
the program is pretty long but let's
just hope it runs
here it is
now the contents are last element
let's have a look whether it is right or
not
one is displaying nine times then last
element we have added two
then we have removed that element
it is also correct then the first
element we have added using insert 7 is
there
and after using clear function
now the size is 0 so this is the correct
output
now after doing this function let's try
another example
now here we will do the example of
iterator functions in which first of all
we will add some elements inside the
vector and then we will print them using
iterators
so let's start
first of all name this
vectors
dot
cpp
now first of all we will write the
header file
hash include iostream
then
the header file for vectors hash include
vector
then
we'll use namespace standard
now we'll start with int main
so here we will write vector
and inside the angle brackets we'll
write the data type that is int and then
the name of the vector that is num
now we will write the for loop and with
the help of for loop we'll add
the elements inside the vector one by
one
so we will write
for
int
i equals 0
i
less than
let's say five
i plus plus
let's make it one over here
okay
now
after that
will push
these elements one by one inside the
vector
so we will write the function
pushback we'll write num dot
push back
and
here i will write i
okay now
because we want to add the elements from
1 to 5 so that is why we have to use
less than equal to because we want to
include five also
okay now
we have to print these elements right so
we'll write
first of all we'll display
that output
from
the begin
beginning
to the end
okay
now
now we will write for loop and with the
help of iterators we will print the
elements of vector
so we'll write auto this is the iterator
and
a is the iterator name
then we'll write
num dot
begin
as we know that
begin function points to the
first element of the vector so that is
why we have written num dot begin
now we will write
a
less than
sorry
not equal to
num
dot
and
then
a plus plus
now after that we have written a not
equal to num dot end
and we know that end function returns
the iterator to the end of the vector
and after that we have used increment
operator
so this loop will run from beginning
till it reaches to the end
and inside for loop we will write the d
reference operator with a so that each
element which is getting pointed by a
will display one by one with the help of
loop
so let's write
we'll write
c out
d reference operator a
and then we'll give some space
now let's try to run this
[Music]
this is the output output from the
beginning to end
one two three four five
this is our right output
this is the message which we want to
display and this is the output 1 2 3 4 5
which we want to display which we have
added in the vector and then we have
displayed
so
now let's do
another example which includes the
capacity function
so
we'll make another file
vector3 dot cpp
so in this example we will add some
elements in the vector and then we will
apply some functions on it
so
let's start
first of all we'll include the header
file
hash include iostream
then
the header file for vectors hash include
vector
then we will write the namespace
standard
using name
space std
okay now we will write int main
so first of all we'll write vector
and then the data type
and then the name of the vector let's
say v
now one by one we'll put some uh
elements inside the vector so we'll
write for loop
we'll start with and x equals zero
x
less than equal to 10
x plus plus
because we want to add these elements
so we will write
v dot
push
back
and then we will write x inside the
brackets
semicolon
now here one by one all the elements
from 0 to 10 will be added let's make it
1 to 10
okay now
we will apply some functions on this
vector
so
let's first of all try out the size
function so first of all we'll write
vector
size
is
and then we will write the function
v dot
size
and then we'll write
n l
so this function will tell us the size
of the vector because we have already
added the elements from 1 to 10 so
it will display 10
after that we will use the
try out
the capacity function
we'll write
capacity of vector is
and then we will write v dot
capacity
after that
here also we'll write endl
now
we will use the maximum size
or the max size so we'll write
maximum size
of
vector
is
so in order to calculate the maximum
size we write v dot
max
underscore
size
and l
as we know that v dot size will give us
the size of the vector
and capacity function this function
returns the size that is currently
allocated to the vector container
and
max size
this function returns the maximum size
of the vector
so
all of these functions
result will be displayed because we have
wrote them inside c out
now
let's try another function
that is resize
now in order to resize the vector we'll
write v dot
resize
and then
we'll write
the number that we want to resize it
with
like let's write 5
now in order to check this also we will
display
so we'll write
vector size
after resizing
resizing is
i forgot to put the commas
okay now we'll write
v dot size because now we want to find
the size after resizing
so we have written v dot size
now
after that
we will write endl
okay
now we'll try
the empty function
we'll put empty function inside if
now inside if we'll write v dot empty
equals equals false
it means
if the vector is not empty because we
have written v dot empty equal equal to
false not true
we have written v dot empty equal to
equal to false that means if it is not
empty
then
we'll display
vector is not empty
and in else condition we will write
vector is empty
so here we will write
c out
back
again i forgot to put over here
okay
vector
is not empty
and in else condition
we'll write
vector is empty
so in this question first of all we have
added some elements inside a vector
then we have used v dot size function
then v dot capacity function then max
size function
after that we have resize the vector
and then check it for the size of it
after that we use v dot empty function
so now let's try to run this code
okay i think we have done something
wrong
we haven't put the brackets over here
okay now let's try again
here it is
vector size is 10
because we have put 1 to 10
then capacity of vector is 16 okay then
max size of vector is this
then vector size after resizing
because we have done we have wrote the
number five as we can see
so that is why a vector size after
resizing is five
and vector is not empty as we know
because
inside the vector there are five
elements so it is not empty which is
true
so
these were some examples of vectors in c
plus plus
moving on
stl stands for standard template library
it is a set of template classes that
provide us data structures and
algorithms or containers
it allows the programmer to use
predefined functions which helps them to
write the code quickly and in an
efficient way
for example you are solving a problem
that needs sorting now instead of
writing the code to sort you can make
use of stl
now stl mainly consists of four
components that is containers iterators
algorithms and function objects
so first is containers
these are collection of objects that
store data of similar type in stl we
have different types of containers some
of them are array vector set map and
these containers are generic in nature
so further these containers are of three
types that is sequence container
associative container and container
adapters
sequence containers these are those
containers that can be accessed
sequentially for example vector
dq list or some of the containers that
store data in a linear form
next is associative container
these are those containers that
implement sorted data structures in this
elements are retrieved via keys and each
associative container maintain its keys
in sorted order
example set multiset map and multi-map
after that container adapters these
containers are like sequential
containers but they are implemented by
modifying their interface to provide the
desired behavior for example stack queue
and priority queue are some examples of
container adapters
now coming to iterators in stl iterator
plays an important role as it links
algorithms and containers iterators are
those entities that helps in traversing
through containers
they are used to point at the memory
address of the steel containers
iterators also helps in traversal from
one element to the next element in the
range using operators like increment
operator
i iterator contains two functions that
is begin function and and function the
begin function returns the iterator to
the first element and the and function
returns the iterator to the last element
now coming to algorithms
algorithms in stl can be defined as
procedure that are applied to the
container and provides some operations
on the content of the container
and because stl algorithms are built in
so that is why they save considerable
amount of time
in algorithms we just have to make a
function call and we don't have to write
the lines of code to implement it
now let's have a look at types of
algorithms
first is modifying algorithm non
modifying algorithm sorting algorithm
searching algorithm and numeric
algorithm
modifying algorithms are those
algorithms that make changes to the
sequences
swap and reverse functions are some
examples of it
then non-modifying algorithm
non-modifying algorithm are basically a
read-only function they do not modify
the data on which they work on
some examples are count equal
and search functions
then sorting algorithms
this algorithm is used to sort the
container elements its example is sort
function
next is searching algorithm
as the name suggests this algorithm
searches for the element binary search
algorithm is mostly used search
algorithm
last is numeric algorithm
this algorithm work on numeric values
or we can say it solves some numeric
problems examples are accumulate
function and partial sum functions
now coming to function objects
function objects are also known as
functors a function object is an object
of template class that implements call
operator
this call operator allows the object to
be used with same syntax as regular
function call
for example suppose you have declared an
object obj of a class in which operator
is defined
then you can use the object obj just
like a normal function
function objects also helps in
generating the data and it also helps in
testing
purposes now in order to do some
examples let's move to our code editor
that is vs code
so here we will do an example of vector
container
so let's make a new file
and
let's name it stl.cpp
now we'll add the header files
now writing namespace standard
now
we will add before name space standard
we have to add
the header file for vectors
because we are doing the example of
vector so that is why we have to add the
header file of vector
okay now
we'll write int main
now first of all we'll declare the
vector so we'll write vector
int
within the angle brackets
now we will write
the name of the vector that is v
okay now we have to push
some elements inside the vector for that
we have to use for loop so we'll write
for keyword
and i equals
let's say 1
i
less than
equals 10
i plus plus that is increment operator
ok now we have to push the elements one
by one so we'll write v dot
push
back
and inside the bracket
we'll put i
so the elements
will keep on adding one by one at the
end of the vector
so now we will check the size of the
vector
so we'll write
i'll write the message size
and then the function v dot size
it will tell us the size of the vector
that is the number of elements inside it
as you can see they that we have put ten
elements inside the vector one by one so
it must be ten
so in order to check it we have used
this function v dot
size okay now
we'll use another function
that is v dot resize
it will resize the size of the vector
so whatever we put inside this bracket
like let's say i've put seven so its
size now would be seven
and we need to check this also
so
we'll again use the function
size so first of all we'll display the
message
after
resizing
it becomes
v dot size
it will print the size of the vector
after resizing okay
now
we use another function v dot empty for
that we have to use if condition
so we'll write
v dot empty
brackets
we know that if v dot empty equals true
then it means it is empty and if it
equals false then it means it is not
empty so we'll simply display the
message that
it is not empty
all right see out
and now we will
write
it slashing
not
empty
before go to
write the
commas over here okay
now
in else
we will write
it is empty
it is
empty we can also do this the other way
around like we can put v dot empty
equals to true and then inside that
bracket we can write it is empty but
it's your choice
okay now
we'll display the elements of the vector
for that we have to first
write the
message so we'll write
elements of vector
then after this using for loop and
iterator we will print those elements
so let's do this
we'll write for
and inside for loop we'll write
auto
id
here the auto keyword specifies the type
of variable that is being declared will
be automatically deducted from the
initializer and i t is the iterator
now we'll write i t equals v dot begin
and we know that v dot begin function
will point to the first element of the
vector
so after that we'll write
i t
not equal to
v dot end
and it will point to the last element of
the vector
now we'll write it plus plus
now
we'll print the iterator using the
reference operator
and in order to make some space we'll
write this
now return
okay now
let's try to run this
okay
here is the problem i think
now let's try one another time
here it is
size 10
after that after resizing it becomes 7
firstly we add the elements by pushing
one by one using the pushback function
10 elements were added so size is 10
after that we have resized it so after
resizing it becomes 7
and then we have used the function
empty
so it was not empty so that is why
the message display is not empty
then the elements of vector
before go to pits space over here
and elements of vector one two three
four five six seven
and
that is correct
okay
now we'll do one example of
iterator in this example we'll simply
print the elements of a vector using
iterator
so first of all let's name this
stl2.cpp
now we will write the header files
hash include iostream
in this will add three header files
now we will write
hash include
iterator
because we have to use iterator so that
is why we are doing this
and we also have to use the vector so
we'll write hash include
vector
now
we'll write namespace standard
now we'll start with int main
so first of all we'll declare a vector
in which there are some elements
as in previous question we already
learned how to add elements in a vector
so in this question we'll simply declare
those elements inside a vector so we'll
write vector
inside the angle brackets
now let's say ar is the name of this
vector
now we'll write the
elements
five five elements are there
now we have to declare iterator to a
vector
so
this is how
we'll do it we'll write vector
then
the data type inside the angle brackets
then after this we'll write the scope
resolution operator
like this
now
iterator
keyword
then the name of the iterator that is
ptr
now we'll display the vector elements
using for loop and using the functions
begin and end
so right
first of all we have to
display a message
okay
we'll write
the
elements of
vector
r
okay
now semicolon
now using for loop
will write
the ptr that is the iterator
ar
dot begin
as we know that ar is the name of the
vector
ar dot begin begin function will point
to the first element of the vector
then
p t r
less than
a r dot
end
we know end function
and function will point to the last
element of the vector
okay now we'll write
ar plus plus
sorry ptr plus plus
now we have to display it and
we'll display it using the reference
operator
and the name of iterator that is ptr
make some space
now at last we'll write return 0
now let's try to run this
the elements of vector r as you can see
the elements of vector are one two three
four five
so this is how you can print the
elements of a vector using the iterator
here is the vector and with the help of
iterator we have printed these elements
one two three four five
now we'll do one simple example of
algorithm
first of all let's name this
stl three dot cpp
now in this example we'll use swap
algorithm to swap two integers
and we know that swap is an template
function so let's do this
first of all we'll write
hash include iostream
now using namespace standard
we'll start with int main
first of all we declare a variable let's
say 7
and
second variable
let's say 10.
first of all we'll display the value of
these variables that
before swapping and after swiping so
that is where
we'll write
value of i
now here we'll write
value of j
and
l
okay now we'll use the swap
algorithm
and here we'll mention
the elements we want to swap i comma j
it will simply swap the contents of
these two elements
now we will write
after swapping
handle we'll do same for
j
this is a very basic example but we have
to see the functionality of it
we'll write
handle
okay
now we'll write return 0
now we'll run this
yeah
value of i 7 value of j is 10
after swapping i
10 j7
it will look
better if we have
root like this
let's make it look good
yeah value of i7 value of j is 10 after
swapping i becomes 10 and j becomes 7
so this is how we can swap the elements
using swap algorithm there are some more
algorithms you can try those as well
and now at last we'll do one example of
function object
let's name this as stl4.cpp
all right now
we'll add the header file
hash include iostream
now
we'll write namespace standard
now in this question first of all we'll
start with the function
first of all we'll make a class
class
function
obj
now we'll write access specifier public
hint
here we'll write the
call operator
as we know the syntax
operator
bracket
then
another bracket
for the arguments
and x
comma and
y
so this is the syntax of it and now
whatever we want to do with these two
variables
let's say we want to multiply
so i'll write return x
into
y
all right
as this is a class so we have to write
the semicolon
now we'll write int main
okay now we'll write in pin after inpane
here we'll write the name of the class
because
we have to define the object of it
now the object is
f4
so here class name is function obj
and its object is f o and as i have
explained earlier here i can use f4
object like a normal function because f4
is the object of class function obj in
which call operator is defined so it
will act like a normal function
so now
we'll make a variable let's say multiply
so we'll write mult
equals f4
and because it acts like a normal
function so we'll pass the parameters
four and seven
now in order to display we'll write c
out and
we'll write
multiplication of x
and y
is
now we'll write the name of the variable
mult
because the result is getting stored in
mult variable
now
we'll write return 0
[Applause]
now let's try to run this
here we can see multiplication of x and
y is 28
and that is true 4 into 7
equals 28
so it is working and
this is the example of functor or
function object let's go ahead and have
a look at why enums are used in c plus
enums are short for enumerations
these are basically used when we have
some set of possible values
and we have to select one out of it
for example suppose you are the shop
owner and you have four types of coffee
in your coffee machine
that is cold coffee hot coffee black
coffee and mocha
and you don't want the trouble of
customer putting any other coffee name
in the machine
which is not there
then in situations like these
enumerations are used
because in enumerations we have to
choose from predefined values and it is
also helpful for documentation and
readability purpose
now let's understand what is enumeration
enum or enumeration is a user-defined
data type in which a set of values are
specified for the variable and the
variable can take out any value from the
set of values
and it is also a way to use integers to
represent values
we can assign values to enum but if we
do not assign any value
then the compiler assigns value to them
starting from 0.
coming to its syntax
which is enum that is the keyword for
enumerated type then enumerated type
name is written then under brackets
possible values of type enum are written
for example here enumeration name is
player and values are ronaldo's lahar
messi neymar which are the names of
players
in this example by default ronaldo is
zero salah is one messy is two neymar is
three
because we know by default compiler
assigns them value which start from zero
and so on
but we can change these default values
by assigning values to them
like here ronaldo's value is now 4
salaha's value is 2
messi's value is 8 neymar's value is 1.
now let's have a look at an example in
which we will print the default value of
months
so in this example we have enum name as
months and eliminated values as january
february march and so on
and in order to access these values we
have written enumeration name and after
that the variable
as we can see inside main function m is
the variable and its type is months
now here we have assigned the month
march to the variable m
and then we are printing the variable m
plus one
here plus one will print the value next
to the month march that is three and
similarly if we write plus two then it
will print then one next to it that is
four
these values are default integer values
after printing the output value is 3
because we have printed m plus 1 where m
is 2 and plus 1 makes it 3.
now
let's understand how to use enum with
flags
in this example we will choose a mobile
having any of the two features among
three
here the name of enumeration is mobile
and its enumerated values are battery
capacity camera quality large storage
and we have assigned values to them
1 2 and 4 respectively
and because we are doing this example of
enums with flags that is why we are
using integer values of power 2
because it avoids the overlapping
inside the main function we are using
bitwise or operator because we want to
choose the mobile having both camera
quality and large storage capacity and
we know that bitwise operator adds the
binary of two integers
so the value of camera quality is 2 and
value of large storage is 4.
when we use a bitwise or operator in
between these two features so it will
add up their binary giving the decimal
number as 6
so the output 6 is showing both the
camera quality and large storage are
used
now let's do some examples of
enumeration in our code editor that is
vs code
okay now let's make a new file
and name the file as
enum.cpp
in this example the enumeration name
will be captain and the enumerated
values will be the team members out of
which we will select one member as
captain
and with if condition we will verify if
he is the selected captain or not
it will be a basic example so first of
all let's write hash include iostream
now we'll add the namespace standard
okay now we'll write
enumeration enum
captain which is the name of the
enumeration type
and now we will write the enumerated
values
which is
let's say
avi
said
robbie
sammy
and jake
these are the team members
now we'll write int main
now here we will first of all write
captain which is the name of the
numerator type
then we'll make the variable out of it
cap
and let's say avi is the captain so
we'll write a v
now here we will write if condition
will write
if cap equal to av
then we'll display
our captain is away and its value is
whatever the value this avi's value here
is zero so we'll display that
so we'll write
our captain
is a v
its value
is
then we'll write av
as we know that av is at first position
then its value would be default value
would be zero
okay so
here we will write endl
now in else
here if we put
said robbie sammy jake as captain or we
if we declare them as captain then this
message would be declare which we will
be writing in else
so the message would be
he is not our captain
then over here we will write return zero
okay now let's try to run this
our captain is away and its value is
zero
because here
captain we have declared a v so that is
why this is printing if we write
let's say
sammy over here
then it will print the else part
he is not a captain
and if we write jake or said
then also it will print the same
he's not a captain
only in case of avi it will print our
captain is away and its value is
avi's value
so this was the basic example of
enumeration now let's move on to one
another example
now
let's make a new file
and name it as enum2
dot cpp
okay
now we will add the header files hash
include iostream
and using namespace standard
so here we will do an example in which
enumeration name will be supercars and
to the values we will assign some
integers to them
which will be the speed of those cars
and then we will compare them using
comparison operator in terms of speed
so
we will write enum
the name of enumeration that is let's
say supercars
okay
now inside the bracket
we'll write the name of the cars which
are the values
and we will assign some integers
these integers are actually speed of
these cars
then
valkyrie
speed is 240
now roadster
okay now
as you have created the enum now we will
start within main
so we will write the numerator type name
supercars
now the variable speed one because we
want to create two variables in order to
compare them so
first we will create speed one
now again
speed two
now we will assign the two cars that we
want to compare to these variables
so
speed one will be
valkyrie
and speed 2 would be
roadster
okay
now we will write the if condition
and inside the f condition we will
compare the speed of these two cars
so we will write speed one
if speed one is less than
speed two
okay
then we will print
that it's a win for roadster
because speed 2 is roadster and speed
one is valkyrie so we'll write it's a
win for roadster
with the speed we'll also write the
speed with the speed
of
this speed 2 will display the speed of
roadster that is 250
okay now
else condition
so here we will write
it's a win for
valkyrie
with the speed
of
here we will write speed one
okay
now we have to write into main but
before that we will write the bracket
which we forgot to mention
return zero
okay i think it's done
now let's try to run this
here we can see it's a win for roadster
with the speed of 250 as we know that
the speed of roadster here is 250 and
the valkyrie speed is 240
so when we compare it
speed 2 that is roadster wins because
roadster is 250
so this was the second example now let's
do one last example
let's name this
okay
enum3.cpp
write hash include iostream
now name space standard
now in this example we will see how to
use switch statement with the
enumeration
okay so
first of all
inside int main
we will write
enum
color is the name of the enumeration
type
then we'll write the values
red
blue
green
and yellow
these are the values
now
here we will use swiss statement
but before doing that we have to assign
one color to a variable
so first of all we have to create that
variable
and in order to create the variable we
will write the numeration type name
color
and then
the variable name select
now we will assign
one color from the above colors
let's say
yellow
now in switch statement we will write
first of all we will write switch
statement
switch
and
we will pass here the variable that is
select
basically we are passing yellow
because yellow is assigned to the
variable select and that is why it is
getting passed
so now
case one that is case
read
first of all we'll write the case read
with a colon in the end
now we will
print that it is red
now we'll write the break statement
break statement basically ends the case
or terminates the case
so after that
the second case that is case blue
colon
now here we will print
it is blue
and similarly
break statement
will do same for all of these colors
green and yellow also
and switch statement will help us to
find which color is passed and will
display the message of that color
so here we will write
green
it is green
break statement
now case yellow
now we'll write it is yellow
now he will write break
okay now at last we have to write return
zero
now as we know that we have we have
passed a particular color
to the variable select and select
is the expression and switch statement
will help us
in comparing the variable select value
to the value of different blocks and one
which matches that particular block will
execute
okay now let's try to run this one
here we can see
it is yellow is being printed
which is the right answer because we
have passed the color yellow to the
select
and that is why only the case yellow
output is being printed
so
this is how you can use switch statement
with enumeration in this session we are
going to learn about c
gui that is graphical user interface and
how to configure visual studio and make
a gui application to develop c
gui or c plus plus graphical user
interface apps we must have an ide
that supports c
gui applications
and visual studio is one of the best ide
for that
here ide stands for integrated
development environment
there are many versions of visual studio
for gui apps
but i suggest you to download visual
studio 2019
there are three editions of visual
studio 2019 that is community
professional and enterprise
we can download the community edition
once the visual studio is downloaded and
installed then you need to launch this
application
after that you can select the color
theme
and change the development settings to
visual c plus
then the visual studio will look like
this
then here we will click on this create a
new project
and now we have to search for a project
template named clr
emptyproject.net framework
so we'll type
clr
empty project.net framework
here it is
make sure that there is dotnet framework
over here now all we have to do is to
click on this
and
select next
now here
we can name our project let's say i have
named it project2 and we can select the
location
and now we can click on this create
button
now our project is being created
so here it is
so now let's create a form file by going
to the project
then add item
add new item
now here visual c plus plus
under visual c plus plus we'll click on
ui and then windows form
we'll click on this windows form and
click on this add button
so our file is loading
so it will show you this error but you
don't need to worry about this one you
can simply close it
now we will go to project
then into properties
then now we'll click on this linker
open this linker
now we'll go to the system
then inside this subsystem
over here we'll select
windows
here it is
now after doing this then we go to
advanced
and in advance we can change this
entry point to main we'll write main
main
this main is the starting function
now we can
press ok over here
now you need to open this myform.cpp
here it is
and you have to copy this code
and just paste it over here
we will add this code in the description
you can take this code from there and
add it
now make sure to write your project name
over here
like my project name is project 2
so i'll write
project
2.
yes
so after doing this we can save it by
pressing ctrl n s
and now we can go to myform.h
here we can see there is no form so we
need to
save it and close this
visual studio once
now we need to open the visual studio
again
we'll go over here we'll write visual
studio 2019 here it is we'll click on
this
and this is launching
we can click on this project too
now
let's go to
myform.h
we'll click on this
it is getting loaded
here we can see the form
earlier we are only able to see the code
but now we can see this form
now we can check this by running it by
clicking on this local windows debugger
button we'll click on that
and let's see if it is running or not
it will take some time
so here it is it is running properly as
you can see this is my form
and
this is ready to use
so it is the debugging is going on so if
we have to close the debugging or stop
the debugging we can click on this cross
button
so the debugging is closed now and we
have verified that the form is running
correctly
we can also add some buttons and labels
to this form like this we can click on
this tool box
then we can select this button
and we can click this over here
so this is our button and we can select
some more labels
all right we can click on this toolbox
again
and select another button
like this over here
and
now
we can select a label let's say
and click over here
and we can also adjust the size of these
buttons
like this
and like this we can adjust the size
and this is the label
we have to adjust his size by setting
its format we can
do it by
clicking on this label
and going to properties
over here we can see as you have clicked
on the label
so we can see the text that is label one
here we can see text
label one
so it is this text which is written we
can change this one
by clicking on this we can select
hello there we can write like this and
it will be shown over this side
now
we must click
the label first then only we can access
the
button or label
so now let's say this is the font so we
can click on this font
and adjust this
here it is let's say
i have adjusted it to 18 size and
made it bold now we can click this okay
on this side so here we can see hello
there it is bold now
similarly we can do this for button as
well
as we have clicked on this button as you
can see
now i can go to this properties
now
inside this properties there is text
that is button one we can see we can
change this like we can write click here
and
we can also adjust its font
here it is
let's say 12
and bold oblique
click on this okay and here it is
click here
we can adjust it over there and suppose
if you want to delete some
button or label or something like that
so we can click on this
and
right click on this side and here we can
see delete we will click on this late
and
it will be deleted
there are more options in toolbox like
there is text box
list box list view
picture box
check box etc we can select as per our
choice
and
we can adjust its layout or editing by
going to the properties column
so now let's make a calculator program
so for that we have to create a
calculator layout so let's just delete
all these
delete this one
and we'll delete this one as well
now we'll go to the toolbox
and select a text box we can search it
over here
text box
here it is we can click on that
and put it over here
here it is
we have to adjust its formatting so
we'll go to properties and
we'll go to font
and click on this font
now let's say adjust it to
and
make it bold
bold oblique yes
i will click on this ok
and
we have to create another one so
instead of doing this all we can copy
this one and to copy this we can go to
this side and click right click over
here
and we can click on this copy
and then we can paste it
here it is because we have to enter two
numbers and for that we need to have two
text boxes for a calculator
all right now in between we can mention
the
operation or operator whatsoever for
that we can we have to select the label
and we go to toolbox
and
here it is
box
but we have to select
label
all right
we'll click on this label and
put it over here
now we have to adjust it
now here we will write
let's say its font would be
and
it would be bold oblique
it will look nice then click on ok
now we have to adjust what is written
inside it so we can go to text and click
on this
label one now
we can write operator
but it would be so long so we can write
op
that means operator
all right
it gives the idea
about the operator
we have to adjust it a bit
all right here it is
and
okay now we have to create a buttons for
addition subtraction multiplication so
we'll go to toolbox
and now we'll
search for buttons
we'll click on button and put it over
here
and now we'll adjust it by going to
properties
and going to fonts
let's adjust it to
and make it bold
now we'll click on ok
and now we have to change the label of
it
first of all let's select
its layout like this
it would be
big
now we'll go to properties
and
we'll go to text
we'll make an addition sign over here
and now i'll click on this so here we
can see so now we'll copy this button to
create the
next three buttons so
click on this copy and paste it
we'll do this for the other two as well
and we'll change the text by going to
properties later
onwards here it is
so first will be addition then here
let's make it
subtraction we're going to
properties we'll click on this
properties
now
let's make this text as
minus
all right now we can also change the
color of this text
let's say
we can make this
this will here it is
blue in color now we'll change this one
we'll go to properties and
make this as
sign of multiplication but we'll press
x
so that will look nice
all right now
this one
will go to properties and change this to
division sign
and we can change this one as well
it will look nice
let's make it this similar color to the
subtraction
all right here it is here are four
buttons addition subtraction
multiplication and division
now we have to display the result as
well so
we'll go to toolbox
and we'll search for label
we'll click on this label
and put it over here
all right
let's make it like this and let's put it
over this side it will look nice over
here
properties now
we have to adjust it
let's make it 22
bold oblique
okay
here is our result and let's name it as
result as well we'll go to text here it
is labeled to return
we'll write
result
now whatsoever operation is done its
result or output is displayed over this
side
now all we need to do is to add the
functionality to these buttons
so let's do that we'll click on this
two times
on this button and the button name
actual name of that button is button one
so here it is
so this part is for button one and we
know that button one is addition so we
need to do addition over here
so let's start
first of all we'll
[Music]
we'll have to declare a variable
int result or output or
answer whatsoever we want
let's write output
now to add those we need the names of
those two text boxes
so we'll go to format
design and we need these names both of
these text box names so we'll click on
this first
and we'll go to properties so here it is
text box one we can see
and we click on this
and properties this is text box two
and this is similarly this is button one
button two button three button four
we can check this by going to properties
and by clicking them and going to
properties so this is text box one and
this is text box two
so now we know the names
now all we have to do
is to write
text box
text box where b is capital
we have to write the exact name we can
check it over here that this is text box
we can check the spelling
this is text box two this is label one
this is button one this is button two we
can
check the spellings from there now
now we have to use the
arrow operator
we'll write like this this is the air
operator this will give us the access to
the members of the object
all right so
we have to change the text so we'll
write
text
with t capital
all right now we have to add
the text box too
and we'll do it same
we'll write
this ad operator
and text
now this addition which we have written
over here is wrong
because we are actually adding the
strings
as you can see
when we type any number over here it is
a string and same goes for this part
so we have to convert it
first we will convert both of these
text to integer and then we will
again convert the result into string
because we have to display it over here
and for that we need a string so then
again we have to convert it to the
string
and let's do it
so what we're gonna do is we'll write
system
and then the scope resolution operator
convert
again scope resolution inverter
operator sorry 2
and
i must be capital keep in mind to int 16
all right now here we'll write
text
box with b capital
and then this add operator
and we'll write
text
all right
after that sign of addition
again we'll do the same
system scope resolution operator
convert scope resolution operator
and
text box 2 here we have to write text
box to
arrow operator
text
all right
here is the addition part now we have to
display the result
now to do that first check the name of
the result like this is the result we'll
click on this and go to properties
its name is label 2
so we have to make the changes into
label 2. we'll go to this
format
now we'll
have to change the text that is we have
to change the result that is written
into the
output
so for that we will write
label
2 which is the name
then this arrow operator
after that we'll write text because we
have to change it
and then
we'll write
system
scope resolution operator
convert
to string because we have to display the
output into string
as i have already told you
all right
now
over here we have to write
output
this output
okay
so let's check if it is working or not
we'll go to local windows debugger and
click on this
hope it works
here it is
my form so let's try to add
let's say five
plus
nine
and we'll click on this add button
fourteen and we know that five plus 9
equal to 14 so
it is working fine we can see and now we
have to do this for all the buttons that
is subtraction multiplication and
division so let's go ahead and do that
let's first close this debugging we have
stopped the debugging and we'll go to
this
now we have to do that for
the next three buttons so we'll
all right
now we'll click on this
subtraction button two times
here we can see
now
the code is same for all of these
and
so we can copy the code from here
and we have just copied it and we'll
paste it
and we'll make the
changes in the sign like i have used
here
minus sign for the subtraction
and the rest is good yeah
all right now we'll do it for the next
one that is
multiplication and double click on that
and here it is
we'll copy the code from here
and paste it
we'll change the sign
the subtraction note the multiplication
sign this is this multiplication sign
and now
the next one that is division
here we go
we'll again select
copy
and paste
let's change the sign of this as well
okay
as we have done the changes so let's
save it by pressing ctrl n s
and
it is saved now let's try to run this
hope it works we'll click on this local
windows debugger
it usually takes some time and here it
is
so let's try now
five
plus
six let's do this first of all edition
now
we'll do
20 minus
6 so we'll click on this minus
and 20 minus 6 equals to 14 that's right
and now we'll do 20 into
3 that is 60
click on this multiply sign 20 into 3
that is 60 it is right
now let's say
15 and
3 yeah
we click on divide and this is five
so all of our
buttons is working fine so this is how
we can create a calculator
in visual studio 2019
you can also create this calculator
program in your pc all you need to do is
to download visual studio 2019 and
install it and you can follow the steps
and you can create this calculator
application
so with that we have come to the end of
this video i hope it helped you all in
understanding the c
concepts
thank you so much for being here stay
safe and keep learning